[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it was a struggle
today for some reason
what's up ripe green potato
[Music]
what's up
live Supremacy was going on Max what's
going on you know what I'm saying Thomas
Pilates what's up Mr ordinary VX what's
going on James you know what's going on
he said say okay let's save another
boring Sunday well I'm glad y'all
appreciate it film watching what's up
David all right what's up hustling
motivate what's going on talk to me
y'all we already know DC in the building
what's going on pop now what's up the
forza Legend what's going on I like that
name
there
so we looking to have a good one just
don't realm the Brethren talking that
talk you know and uh so far man we got
some good topics some spicy ones Derek X
what's up Derek excuse me what's up
thanks what's up yeah man we got some
good stuff to talk about I see y'all
tick-tocking over there supporting us
over there that's love a lot of dope
over here I appreciate the love seeing
new people find out about us thank you
appreciate you brother big time
here
it was a good thing we tested this out
now
still a big show yeah oh it's the loser
I'd have got the new setup y'all looking
clean I see it see how you like it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
here you man welcome to the show if you
would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all the good stuff that we need
to do in um you know we're about to get
started I am well it's not important to
who I am uh what's important is that you
are pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when he was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social knowing my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start it regardless back weed with
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I ain't
heard the boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell an Uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
and we are alive I Am Lord podcast Lord
Cognito here talking about the latest
with Advanced GG there's a lot of things
going on with the new product live let's
get right to it
so we got that Focus line y'all this is
that standard that's what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
game in we don't use coffee anymore
we're utilizing this focus on debt
number two you already know it's my
favorite right here the energy line you
already know birthday cake one of my
absolute favorites completely delicious
this is a pre-workout equivalent and
also doesn't use beta Adeline so you
don't get the Jitters and stuff like
that so it's really good for that and
then the new new we got that hydration
line y'all this is really good for
people who don't like caffeine who want
an electrolyte substitute and it is
really sugar-free absolutely delicious
so you got your three choices once again
you know Cog love is sour you already
know and we're doing this right now so
go get yourself to advancedg.com use
code iron Lord on a checkout this is
something I use all the time got to
support Advanced EG great products if
you want to get your workout on even if
you don't work out you're just gaming
you need that focus and again the
hydration in line for those who don't
want caffeine no sugar electrolytes
you're good to go lower Cognito here
iron Lord podcast peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
you gotta do the Pro Bowl like that
but it keeps me safe and warm I can't
your velari situation
[Laughter]
when you be done
the rage you know what I'm saying your
arms you need that support you need that
recipe just put that right on top grab
that controller you know what I'm saying
the cool thing is you can set your
controller in your phone you know what
I'm saying at the same time
so let's go around the horn right and
everybody say how wrong they use it and
then we'll tell you yeah if this is the
correct way
so so so attic how do you use yours
yeah yeah tell the truth
that's your pregnancy pillow
he will bring that up over here
oh you do you know somebody who does a
fair bit of traveling you know my I I
realized that a regular travel pillow is
just not enough for me you know what I
mean I need I need the productness of a
Volari pillow right so I walk in the
airplane you know as you're walking down
the aisle you're just slapping people in
the aisle as you walking down you know
and you know if you're somebody who
feels the need that you have to buy like
an extra seat for your Volari pillow and
this is what you do so I get in there
you know what I mean tied around my neck
nobody's getting close to me man
I have an aisle all to myself
it's gangster you know what I'm saying
this is It's a beautiful thing thank you
for Laurie how do you use your Volaris
so sometimes when my wife is working
downstairs
I'm alone
I like stupid I like to get my valari
pillow and it's it's the premium you see
the stitches
stitching is nuts right so and
embroidered so like I like all and then
if you notice if you look along the
shield the bumps right there they
embroidered white bumps right so what I
do is I just as I'm falling asleep
because you know she's not there I can't
and I snuggled in I like to rub I like
to rub the bumps you got to get you guys
because if you close your eyes you can
read iron Lord's podcast
it gives you the comfort you need
if you really close your eyes and feel
it
it allows me to sleep comfortably
until she returns
oh man here we go let me play with your
you guys know uh a while back lord we
Todd was blessed with a pillow for my
good friends of Alaric and basically the
valari pillow is
for those like Cog was saying those long
gaming sessions you kind of wrap it
around your waist and if you think about
it if you're if you sit on the couch you
sit on a chair whatever if you're gaming
for a long time you're probably leaning
forward or your arms are probably
getting tired your arms are getting like
falling asleep actually
this is this is the thing that you don't
realize you need until you have it and
you're like oh my god what have I been
doing so you wrap this around your waist
it's it it's it's very Hefty as you can
see yeah your arms on it as you're
dancing it's crazy thick and it allows
you to to game super comfortably in a
way that again it's something you don't
realize that you need until you use you
know Advance it because you should have
to you know I I don't have the
opportunity to do it that much anymore
but it's funny with the steam deck the
steam deck afterwards it's a little
Hefty yeah and you get arrested you can
rest right on it and it really is an
amazing product that when I first looked
at I was like yeah this is excessive but
it's not but it is amazing it's amazing
yeah let me tell you mine right I was
playing fortnite
so I was playing for a minute I probably
got into probably like seven sessions
right and I was like man this gotta be
my last one and I noticed though I
looked over at my couch and I noticed my
elbow indent into the couch right so
wifey's like you're gonna destroy your
couch you're gonna destroy your couch
your couch is done so I was like my
pillow came get my pillow I put my
pillow on I got my pillow here right now
and I put my elbows in and I was like oh
snap you see how my arms is resting just
like that just completely natural all
right so I put my mom's and I'm playing
remember I was like five to seven
matches in when I looked up I didn't
finish my whole battle page
because I just was just gaming and my
elbow was not indenting in the cushion
my hands didn't get tired I wound up
changing my battery though
that's when I realized how far I went
and where I was at with it but at the
same time I was just completely zoned
out I got a chance to zone out and play
my game yeah and I didn't worry about uh
any inks or pains or whatever that was
going on and I'm just telling you I mean
as a younger game but probably you lean
forward and do stuff bad as me I'm an
older gamer at some point in time you
got to get up you gotta move around you
got to stretch and stuff or your arms
get kind of tight your hands get kind of
tight I didn't it's no cap I just didn't
yeah yeah yeah I'm sorry and I want to
point out you know uh
companies reach out to us such as Villar
because of the support you guys get you
guys come in here and and hordes man
like hundreds of hundreds of you every
week you know uh you know we couldn't do
any any type of thing we do in the
future it can only be done because you
guys show up and you support to the max
every week absolutely absolutely I put I
pinned it at the top right now we're
going to have a an initiative with
Volari probably pop off that's exclusive
Edition joint you know what I mean that
y'all saw go hit them up they will be
putting up the uh pre-order page and
stuff like that so you could go get the
official IOP joint you know what I'm
saying now also along with the
embroidered
um logo that's that's in the front right
you see that logo there and I'm talking
about this real premium stuff yeah it's
premium y'all you also have our IOP
um I I like to call this you know the
street uh logo The Joint that we got you
know so you have that logo here but also
on the other side you have the official
Glory you know um embroidered here yeah
so if you if dudes ever play that
knockoff game
you double check you make sure that it's
embroidery there also when you when you
put it right you get that snap in and
you understand that nice snap that
crispy grip you know because everybody
right here
they've got that grip it ain't about
that yeah
I actually love it don't snap around my
waist but
I actually love it actually yeah yeah if
I'm not then it's a problem baby
but you zipping in is a nice zip yes
right so if you're gonna clean it it's a
nice zip jump premium pillow separate
yes take this take it out put it to wash
and I would say um take it to the dry
cleaners because when you feel it it
feels like leather you know it feels is
really a premium situation
um these is going to go up they ain't
gonna be cheap yeah but repeat that part
it's a premium product y'all yeah yeah
we we calling out for all the people of
the realm you know to get together and
this is this is if if any people are
watching that want to get a good gift
for somebody for Christmas yeah this is
accessory give them that switch give
them this because they don't need that
because you know the eyes and cataracts
you want to support them Yo don't do
switch like that
you want to be as close to this week
or the Ragnarok you won't play the
Ragnarok you know what I'm saying throw
this throw this with that rag the rocket
but real talk yeah same thing for me
like the way I utilize it shout out to
our good friends of valari the way I
utilize it is because look you think
about it as a gamer you're holding the
controller like this for hours or most
likely a very hard rigid surface most of
these what you call these rats are very
rough if they don't have cushioning
don't have padding and it's really not
good for your posture it's really not
good for your joints and stuff like that
that's how arthritis about stuff all set
throw that pillow on have it set the
most comfortable thing you won't even
realize about it's really great so
salute to them like I said it's up we'll
be putting up an official pre-order page
for the real stuff but go hit up Volari
tell them that you saw it that you're
interested you know what I'm saying
because they're gonna be doing a
pre-order page with us so that is it so
what's up with yourself as soon as we
get the page up the exact page link is
going to be in in the chat and we'll put
it up on uh you know Tick Tock Twitter
everywhere yeah they're gonna be all
over the place no doubt and you want to
get in quick
um you know to pre-order as soon as
possible
it's gonna go oh my uh my significant
other is yelling into my phone
texting of all caps it feels like suede
she has shoulder pain so she actually
tries to steal my pill and I gotta fight
it so I gotta hit a Volari to be honest
with you because I need another pillow
because she's trying to fight me for my
people yeah you're not a Lord You're Not
Alone shout out to Sinister I approved
gaming with a baby lap from from a game
of dance he proves it no doubt so look I
hear you hear you we're live uh welcome
yeah yeah we're live
cats LLC the Lord's gaming.net episode
number 274. another glorious Sunday
we're back in the realm on the round
table with the Lord's date and today
we've got Halo infinite Unreal Engine
rumors
stadia shuts down and whom they are
blaming
PlayStation Stars loyalty program and E3
2023 to discuss so we go get right into
it so let's introduce the Four Horsemen
of gaming those original gaming Knights
of the realm here at the round table my
co-host with Nicole most my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man Lord Act of
the attic show how we doing sir doing
pretty good uh you know first thing I
want to shout out is a shout out to the
game Dial field Chronicle uh you know
shout out to score Enix too you know you
know what's crazy I have had like
obviously I know when you when you
review game uh you you got to State very
clearly that you know you're getting
that game as a review copy but man
Square you still play you're like I was
reading it's like you gotta say that you
got it every 20 minutes if you live
streaming yeah it's just like they want
to know that they they they cooperating
it's just like you know I like the game
I really I really enjoy what I've been
playing I do have some some gripes with
it uh quite a bit of grapes I showed
Cognito before the podcast like this
giant spreadsheet sort of notes
yeah so uh you know I don't know when
I'll be reviewing this game because I
have another game that I'm supposed to
get Monday and I don't know if I'm gonna
be finished with this by then uh so and
I feel like that game because I try to I
try to capitalize on Indie Games as much
as I can to help them with with the
coverage on those games because I feel
like you know the dive for the chronicle
it it is a score Enix game they got a
lot of money pushing that but a lot of
these Indie developers they don't got
that type of money so that is true that
is true salute that I've ever been
playing the demo I can't wait for your
review on that officially anything else
you've been playing sir
uh that's about all now obviously I have
my daily routine of popping in on a
on Destiny and seeing if there's any
mods because what's funny is it was like
two raids ago I couldn't make nothing no
builds because I had no mods yeah so I
was like I don't care if I'm not playing
this game anymore I'm popping in every
day for five minutes to see each of us
every day that's what's up well I have
pretty much all the Banshee ones okay
but it like it's because because she's
got like uh Ada's got like the class mom
yeah specifically and that's what's
important and I'm sitting there looking
through these and what's funny is like
there's one that I still have not been
able to get it's it's one for my void
it's I can't remember what exactly what
it's called at this point but uh shout
out to them because what's cool is devil
lets you like yank other people's builds
just to try it out and like so like you
know ask your cross people like that
what they'll do is they'll try out all
these unique builds and they'll make a
dim link and what it is is they'll put
it in the in the description of that
video they're talking about it you could
click on that and you can literally as
long as you have everything that that
build has it will try it will change
your Titan to their Titan and so because
the I don't got time to be doing what
car does anymore
I'm trying to stay away from giving my
life to one game man I I'm trying to
open B variety
I'm gonna pop in there put it in YouTube
what's the best Titan void build of 2022
and the first one pop up that's what I'm
using
the cool thing is when light four comes
out they're actually going to integrate
a dim light system finally in game so
you can switch between the bills it's
about time budget how you gonna let
other people do your stuff for this this
long salute why don't you forget it
right
anyway and of course we have almost
technically someone said show me your
build crafting oh here we go they back
in the show your bills score okay okay
z-man that's good shout out to mass all
the fun speculation up in the house very
no and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo game who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Davis the
Lord of clarity and location of the iron
bank my man Lord sorry for now we doing
sir I am good children I've been coming
in super hot today man I I put the alarm
for nine o'clock and I'm usually
um
you've been commenting about your uh
close to being tardiness every week
because I'm usually you know me I was
the 11 o'clock or like yeah let's do it
yeah what happened
age I don't know what it is when I was
when I was talking uh to Cog before the
podcast I'm like soft has like the
ultimate skill to pop into like right
before he's technically like and I'm
just like I look up like I turned it off
I'm like but turning it off means that
my natural like internal clock is like
it'll be 10 I get up 10 easily make
breakfast whatever because on the
weekend I make breakfast because wifey
takes care of me all week Saturday
Sunday I make breakfast you're such a
good guy
such a good guy that's right I I don't
share any of that
he's like no what is that place over
there with the refrigerator what is this
you know what it is you know what it is
and I'll be real
I got places in this house that I go
that she don't go and then she got
places that she go that I don't go I
please the only way I go to the kitchen
is when I'm going to through the kitchen
to the kitchen someplace else
[Laughter]
so I wake up but it's noon and I'm like
oh
whoa yeah so yeah coming in super hot
but I made it I made it just uh 12 59 I
believe
what you could play sir uh yes it's a
starter spooky season so I said let me
look into something spooky to play right
so I was playing the demo of the
mortuary assistant oh you played it oh
yes
yo tell me to enjoy that crazy yeah yeah
it is Bonker so he's bombing him out of
the game yes but with like demons yeah
yeah so it's a full game out I don't I
have the demo I don't know if the full
games out but I if it is when I was at
Pax West it was out I believe that day
it came out it was like out now so it's
out it should be out yeah so we have
that and then I jump back into dead
space I had Dead Space on Steam for the
longest time
um so I said let me throw it on the deck
and see how that runs like
bro that game starts yes this the look
you know obviously we played on the 360
back in the day they got the stop
stitching
cups
shout out to tease
oh my God
there's so many wow
continue sub I didn't realize what this
man was doing so yeah Dead Space on the
steam deck is amazing I have it all
running at 60 High settings and it's
again it's much better than the 360
version we played back in the day bro
like everything about that the
atmosphere even the jump scares still
work the gameplay it's uh so I'm excited
I'm excited for the Remake in January
and I'm excited for um Callisto protocol
in December yeah absolutely you know
closer product has an achievement in a
trophy for experiencing every death that
the game has yeah it doesn't tomb raid
to have something like that too like you
know when Laura dies in her games it's a
spectacular
so I can imagine because it's kind of
gross the the stuff that I've seen so
far from the death animation is kind of
crazy so
yes tonight I'm gonna actually get a
chance to really play I don't want to
comment on it yet because I only had
like limited time but yeah that's a
that's all for y'all right now crazy
sandbox oh bone Labs yeah that's right
crazy citizens
yeah that's the VR game is it wait so is
it different to Bone works it's a part
two to that yeah okay yeah yeah so
basically yeah kick already explained it
that's it
they they went way really okay because
besides besides Half-Life Alex like
boneworks is that game you like oh I can
do that
yes and then you get your avatar change
its size and then yeah yeah it's crazy
yeah
it's I'm I'm a fraud well let me I'll
get to my joint yeah sorry sorry
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the excess gamer oh the
prophet of Xbox
Swami King of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement oh beloved
not with the establishment already not
with the stop stitching already oh
there's going to be a lot of that okay
he brings the mug up quite slowly to the
camera like like the stuff normally
normally what what when King does his
stop snitching stuff I'm like you know
what it is what it is but I'm a I'm
gonna be right there with them tonight
we will discuss clearly continue King
what's going on okay so uh this week I
was like it's so many things that
dropped inside Game Pass and I was
trying to finish off a couple of things
so
Destiny I feel at it with all that stuff
that he said you go in there and you go
look at your minds and your mind's just
dead like what these mods that I was
using before that were so metal before
are no longer there so you have to go
get mods and place mods inside and you
feel like a a new Guardian all over
again just trying to get your build
right and um and they they worked with
The Arc
um Arc is crazy this season for some
weird reason
um so I'm working with that and trying
to finish my season pass but at the same
time I'm finished trying to finish my
battle pass in fortnite because they got
this little Gummy Bear dude that I like
with this little teddy bear dude in the
stomach
I want the I want the the Gwen one the
the Spiderman yeah but she's at the end
they they always have the dope stuff at
the end to make you they force you to
play real hard and so we got to get a
game in today at least at it um because
I mean when me and you play we win
um Moon scars
um
okay
all right so you are a falling God
you're a God That Failed and you down
you they they you like down to earth or
whatever and it it looks like um it
looks like a metroidvania it's inside
Game Pass
um and it's it's it's a 16-bit type of
feel so
that's 16. you're seeing it right now
yeah move scars it looks like you're
fighting with Alucard or something yes
that's what he looks like and that's
what it feels like Moon scars okay okay
um so along with this and and
um Proteus yeah I saw produce last week
they launched two games inside game pass
that gives you that old school
16-bit uh feel at at 60 frames per
second
yeah his move sets that he get later on
fantastic the game feels just right like
and these are these little stop gaps but
when you're playing these long battle
passes are you playing your season
passes or or whatever you playing and
you feel a little bit stuck and you want
some games they got progression inside
these are the games that are there for
you so yeah
[Music]
it's a nice double a game it's really
good to play soundtrack is ridiculous
same thing you messed up that was crazy
yeah
um continue yeah I don't remember seeing
this at all I remember seeing it it got
that because I'm looking at their
Twitter account they damn were humble
and they were okay okay yeah I mean to
be honest with you there's so much going
on at Pax it's impossible to see
everything yeah that's true that's true
this is one of those Little Gems that
drop in there and you get a chance to
play uh shout out to Game Pass for
giving my son Puppy Patrol
so he can knock that out get that free
uh what is it the 1000 game of points
that he'd be doing he's into that mood
now where he's easy 1000 Gamers score
Smooths all over that yeah
this will he be on that yeah shout out
shout out to King Kong the game
oh yeah
Grace used to have uh a decent amount of
gamer score in her old account or
something like that and she was like I
just want ten thousand I was like let's
go to smooth profile
there you go that's how you got your 10
000 in 15 minutes I'll tell you man
this game pass thing is really
ridiculous it's a lot of that hey oh I
downloaded grounded again okay so now I
want to play the finished product
they asking us to play it yeah or us
yeah they asking the laws they like yo
the laws need to play and it's full yeah
I've been seeing I hit you up on Twitter
addict it was all they had asked about
it yeah my drink was um I played it when
I was a baby boy you know I stepped back
away from it I was like whenever it's
done you know these spiders had me
scared
yep so I'm playing now so okay it's cool
yeah you gotta check it out so it's been
pretty much it King yeah that's about it
oh
um shout out to ducky yo y'all no ducky
uh I'm there I'll get it in sir I
apologize him and and the team yes
they've been waiting for you they've
been waiting for you he got things lined
up like shout out to Dougie hit me up
last night I think I was playing uh
grounded for low I mean uh I'll do
something with Destiny for a little bit
but I was like bro I can't do a raid
right now like I got things these dudes
is red they raid like that that's about
that's the T they got the checkpoints on
Deck you already know and of course we
got the gaming himself
considering how long we played oh yeah
raid last so we probably did the the
ending encounter on Val like what 30 40
times trying it oh that's probably
exaggerating but you get what I'm saying
shot the city stop it Liz shout out to
everybody up in there that came through
DJ was it but not Forte before I yo yeah
[Laughter]
had a good one talk about the Activision
doing all that good stuff talking about
obsidian if they hold it down Xbox and
all that good stuff
um we did a good defiling Duke ultimate
talking about E3 which we will get into
later as well our specific memories and
stuff like that shout out to the last
word he bought this tiger Travis we have
my man glow up in there yo he's a super
knowledgeable cat really breaking down
she's another plunder story as well as
the PVP see what's going on there and
then for me gaming yeah grounded has
stolen it man grounded
I I gotta I got a call for all of myself
like y'all remember I remember the
trailer when that game debut
I was like what are you doing going in I
was like what do you do why I was like
who wants this who needs this song I was
like and then that was the time right I
remember exactly because that was around
the time like around series X stuff's
coming out and like people like yo
where's the power at outside of like
Hive Busters you know what I'm saying
gears or maybe a couple other choice
people was like yo where's the power at
so I'm like Oh serious new joint side
project let's see
I shook the kids drink and I'm like oh
man they say that you know what I said
so I gotta keep it a buck like I I
played very briefly the what is what we
doing the beta you know what I'm saying
and I was like nah I'm not gonna be a
beta boy for this Joy I'm good stepped
out of that I was all right cool so now
the finished product I'm like all right
let me see what's going on shout out to
Thai Guy Travis he was one of the ones
that was really like yo shout out though
I think red too shout out to red but
Tyga was gonna play meal he's like I'm
gonna tell you right now he's like I
don't like these survival choice at all
he is like I don't play them he's like
destroy got a story he was like do I
can't stop I was like really try I'm
grounded he's like yeah man I jumped up
in there I was like all right I'm gonna
play this was the player I was going to
play cyberpunk because I'm getting my
age running so I'll play a side [ __ ]
heavy side [ __ ] like a new game to me
kick you know it is it is it's the back
yeah it's a new game then I'm like all
right death Loops out you know what I'm
saying so I'm like oh yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying dude
yeah you know the Rock at all I actually
pulled over there I gotta get back onto
it but so to myself yeah I got yes we
got a drag so the thing is I did the
joint and for I like for the hour I'm
gonna play you get back to business man
if that one hour it turned to an all
night
yeah it's something about the last night
no not last night this was um the day it
came out the um what was it Tuesday when
one point officially the thing about it
is I'm gonna be real like most survival
dreams I you give me too much freedom
and give you a twig and a rock and go
make fun I ain't doing none of that that
I I just I shout recipes dizzy like he
used to love that Arc stuff yeah not
only first of all this Joy got a lot of
Polish to it right second it holds your
hand for for idiot like me who don't
play that and be like God go over there
and get this Pebble and put this Rod
together and make it action you can
start chopping down trees then go over
there and do this and make this shovel
so you can start digging up and go like
it starts telling you the basic stuff
and then this cool thing it got is once
you you take these little you take your
little things you find like take you
take a rock you take whatever you find
and you go back to the little base and
they got this little analyzer and the
analyzer when you analyze it it then
tells you stuff you could make it tells
you the pieces you need to make it I
said oh this is for me it is the kick
the thin King it got
and then what is the story though I
don't want to spoil it okay I don't want
to spoil it but here this is where the
game is fire
the game low key turned into a horror
game but if you out at night yeah first
of all music did the mood change then
like you're so small in this world so
you see the tree splitting in the
distance and you're like what the hell
is that coming towards
be a ladybug or a spot and then the
crazy thing is you think you tough so it
was one time it was like I saw a lady oh
it's a lady some of the strongest things
lead ladybugs alone leave them alone
they don't bother nobody they mad
peaceful they be mine yeah don't they
don't bother you don't mess with them
don't mess with the bees the ones that
got me though is the lightning bugs oh
look at the little flash so I got my
little mix shifting I was like yeah he
gonna have good materials
he turned around King his eyes got red
it was like what's goody good it chased
me all around it
I said oh I said oh you ain't go free it
really is good and you can control the
survival aspects like I'm playing
realistic with the food and the water so
I'm looking for a little do jobs I'm
creating my little thing I'm constructed
I got a little shish kabob dig while I
make my little food in the morning so
you could skip over all that again
solve they got the stuff for you if you
don't want to do none of that take the
settings or it tells you to begin you
want to play with the survival settings
or you don't care about that you just
want to play through the story do that
I'm gonna tell you right now bro like
the game they they did that they they
really it has an obsidian chart it's
polish Story music everything they did
that I got a better knee I was wrong
about grounded I thought this was the
worst decision for them to ever make and
this turns out to be going to be one of
their best games so go check it out if
you've seen what we've seen but anyway
so I've been doing that and uh yeah we
got to get into I think we're gonna
describe right now
subscribe them up let's go give me a
second I gotta I gotta get this crap
forgot to get described videos got so
excited about crafty yeah don't think I
didn't see you R Kelly
yeah
I gotta get what you call it is okay
yeah cool yeah while you're out there
you know doing that I hope you ain't
behind them Enemy Lines
snitching
you know you ripped them snitches
this describes my
name is about okay cool look at his
background oh hello sir subscribers
ready hold up yeah yeah
I don't mind taking the back seats are
grounded if I need to I got so excited
about grounded I forgot to bring you
so look you already know it's the top of
the vote where we celebrate Lords of
gaming.net man we've been blessed
tremendous Talent bad tremendous Talent
everyone that applies I want to shout
out the whole editorial I got some of
the best editorial team in the business
selfless attention to detail attention
to Quality the sourcing has been
outstanding getting that reputation
that's a really reputable sight addict
you know what I'm saying like I'm loving
what I'm seeing there and to see people
give like Brad Sam's chess courting give
Lord to gaming.net they love Mr Maddie
plays and everybody that's been shouting
us out you know what I'm saying when we
break itself so competition is fierce
every month you know what I mean we got
some tremendous Riders but it's been one
particular writer that really went Above
and Beyond in the month of September he
killed build it had an exceptional bump
one of the most unique actually never
done before pieces or Lords gaming.net
where he talked about the board game
seeing the table top seat the RPG and
Kingdom Come Deliverance dropped the
board game shout out to the good people
at Warhawk Studios who allowed us to uh
review that uh preview build of it and
he took it home and he did that dig that
so without further Ado we proudly
present the latest winner of the Lord
dizzy logneck scribe of the bump Steve
Perry AKA Laura cross congratulations
brother
thank you guys no death speech speech
well I mean honestly it's just so uh
it's awesome to be recognized among such
a such a great group of folks I mean we
got a lot of great writers on the team
and a lot of writers who are more
prolific than me and I don't get the
chance to write as much as I'd like to
but I just try when I get to write um to
be sure that I that I do that it's
quality work
um it was really really cool to be able
to to preview a game uh that's you know
not even not even uh not even hadn't
been even kick-started yet um but it was
real cool to just mess around with it to
work with War Horse to work with
forcubator and uh yes and I mean what
once it comes forward man I mean I
really had a good time with it so I'm
hoping it all works out for him nice man
yeah man absolutely killed it also I
mean to your credit even before that you
know I know you you down on your writing
uh what you call it your oh the volume
but you've had some great articles
before that you know say even even
grounded which I had talked about you
know what I'm saying you had a good
article on that man it's good to see the
growth there but again we definitely
want to reward those who will go above
and beyond this was actually a big ass
it's different from anything we've ever
done and to see you step up to the plate
knock that thing out was tremendous to
see brother absolute pleasure to have
you on the team make sure you hit solve
up for those nice already done okay I
need the rest of the info but yeah no
doubt make sure you take care of that
man Steve you know every time you win
scribe of the month you have to give us
a rendition of Don't Stop Believing
enjoy your Sunday and it's a pleasure to
have you on the team brother you already
know
enjoy the rest of the conversation no
doubt brother have a good one absolute
no doubt so we got the Super Chat ready
yes sir ready to rock hold on a moment
all right we got a ham solo gaming two
dollars I'm with fam but I wanted to
show my appreciation I don't know what
this was in response to there so I guess
you had a conversation in the chat and
we got
remember for two years two dollar Super
Chat did he say it's thick yes I did I
did say his thing
[Laughter]
how much for the iron Lords Boppy Pillow
cake yeah coming soon it's coming soon
prices will be there um remember I said
it's a premium product trust me once you
receive it you're gonna say damn I need
another one that's on God and then
you're gonna look over to your friends
and be like yo he needs one or Christmas
presents this is gonna be the best
premium Christmas present that you can
give for any gamer trust me you'll see
or or Grandma they'll be sitting there
watching us soap operas or whatever just
throw this around a waste and watch that
smile come on our face
yeah get that TF going yeah you got bad
thing going seconds remember for two
years ten dollars if we chat um are you
guys familiar with the show called The
Boys where there was an episode where uh
Mother's Milk went in Asylum and had a
similar thing wrapped the rise in there
yeah yeah
but this this wasn't as premium
listen trust and believe I mean it may
look you you see it right here on the
video
touching it is two different things
and also it comes in a carrying net
the carry in that is premium as well so
if if again if you ran out of fish in
that you want to catch some fish
no but it's dope like that no doubt we
have a Sith Lord remember for two months
two dollars which had Sony requires you
to spend three hundred dollars for
customer service yes we will address
yeah he will address that yes
is allowed to participate in all the fun
I have to just sit here and watch send
me that cup
anyway then we got oh let's put the
crust in the chat but a six month Mark
of I salvation five thank you sir
welcome to the realm
and we got awful Grim bones five dollar
Super Chat I'm here live no work tonight
y'all are hilarious I love Sundays
because all right Lord I'm listening
while I'm on my way to Mom's for Sunday
dinner yes
delicious yes yes yes and we've got
random citizen once again remember for
two months five dollars apologies I
meant how much for the velocity pillow I
need that yeah uh price is incoming but
as king says a premium product that will
be a pre-order page uh through Volare
coming soon no doubt no doubt now we got
free R Kelly uh-oh five dollar Super
Chat Kang Kojima live the Phil Xbox
getting the cloud game PlayStation get
the stranded too Jim Ryan is King Sony
is dominating I don't know if you want
to be so excited about getting this
branding too but okay so you're getting
death stranded too you don't think we're
getting a whole full package
I bet you're not getting that cloud game
here's the thing though like Cloud
implementing Cloud into a game can mean
a variety of different things
technically Forza Horizon 2 has cloud
infrastructures and yeah so it's just
like just because he came out and said
you know he's making a cloud game does
not mean he's making an only cloud game
no attic don't don't explain the kills
he's got other things to worry about hey
guys he's snitching Behind Enemy nines
now you have been found out and they got
shibs for you sit down they gotta catch
my man
Dodger kidneys
gotta show us paperwork damn he got a
lot of redacted stuff in there oh man
don't do cows like that um
remember for a year five dollars we chat
until they make an actual story campaign
when all those elements of bone lab
slash boneworks is just another over
glorified Tech demo VR needs better damn
oh I believe everything that you're
saying and and
I'm gonna be honest with you yeah that's
true but then Along Comes demio's those
games that do have a complete uh set
from beginning to end
I honestly agree with you I think the
funding needs to be more in the VR
department so a lot of people have to go
out and support until there's one
platform that can identify with the
masses
who has done that I think that has to
happen maybe PlayStation VR2 will do it
but for that 900 price tag I don't think
so
all I would say is people need to try a
bowl out before they come
a lot of people don't make informed
decisions
yeah we got Elliot shlomovitz member for
two years with the 15 shekel super super
chat great day to join the realm live
especially with those topics Xbox game
pass been fire lately and only getting
better in Q4 of 2022 Moon scars as hard
as hell by the way okay that's perfect
yeah I need to play that um now we got
Donald tackle remember for one year five
dollar Super Chat why is nobody talking
about the best game on Game Pass right
now Paw Patrol Grand Prix Mario Kart
better watch this back has got some real
competition I did I talked to him about
it I said my son oh [ __ ] I was a grand
that was a racing game it wasn't like a
regular Paw Patrol again absolute salute
there you go then we got Matt without
fear remember for six months 10 pounds
Super Chat my whole family has been
eating well with Game Pass grounded from
my eight-year-old Paw Patrol for the
four-year-old and thanks to asda's Falls
even my wife has been playing playing
with me happy Lord's day because we have
kids obviously she's been playing with
you before yeah
I know what he said with the
demographics Falls we we covered it that
we told people like that's gonna be a
game I mean it's all short that you
could get your mom to play you know what
I'm saying like you get anybody who's a
non-gamer Microsoft know what they're
doing with the variety of different
things they're not giving you the same
what is it third person over the
shoulder story driven narrative game
remastered remake
are you implying that one company is
doing a similar type game the
homogenization of a certain type of game
you know it's the wildest thing and I
would have I would I would have fell
fool to this all right so I'm bringing
my PlayStation 5 downstairs I'm like
okay let me take you out of the the side
room and let me bring you down to the
main event right so I'm bringing them
down to the main event and my behind was
going to order that last of us remake
joint yeah I'm going through my pictures
tell me why I found out in my pictures I
got The Last of Us remastered for the
PlayStation 4. I said they wait for you
to forget and they go right back here oh
yeah yeah that was that was a good
addiction yes they hustling son I love
it I love that hustle
okay we have what's next uh we got
hargit Chennai remember for you one year
remember 16 months actually Lord gold I
believe I was the first member of the
stop snitch in Brigade wearing this
shirt right now Jim crying dance moves
snitching lion going out to Brussels
gonna be a subject clearly I want
everybody to go out man and support the
movement stop snitching man we can't
have this let's go
flew out all right
man five dollar Super Chat all hail the
king and the Lord's Side the king and
the king and the Lord
if somebody isn't answering the phone
you might not have enough money on your
books and free R Kelly
yo yo yo the commissary low yes that's
crazy he's trying to say all cows can't
be part of the Playstation system
there we got Gerald back five dollars to
test shout out to the homie if the deer
doesn't go through if the deal doesn't
go through how ticked off will Xbox be
70 billion in money hating a worse face
a money hat and the worst rate and it's
true
somewhere they'll take that 70 billion
and go and buy Sony and it's not even
gonna cost 70 billion to buy it
there we go you know the funny thing I
do think that if somehow that deal
doesn't go through
you there's going to be a scenario where
people go like I I honestly feel like
Sony gonna wish they would have just
kept their mouth shut like because sure
they might not they might not buy
something like Sony because I don't
think Sony would sell but they have no
problem out over overpaying for other
stuff and it just put it that way the
hospital takeovers happen every day
[ __ ]
do they really happen every day though
yeah they actually do they you know
we're just not preview to see the dudes
get hostily taken over
moving on so
there we go flame five dollars in the
chat how many buckaroos I've heard if
you spend 300 bucks in super chess you
can get better chat reads as part of the
ILP stock IOP stars is that true that's
good that was actually good that's not
how that goes I mean if you put it in
red this is everybody good created equal
over here we don't do that but if you
put it in red
that's Mitchum beat
okay we got a big mad Mo remember for 27
months thank you sir shout out to the
Lords and the best way to start Sunday
thank you so much
then we got Suicide Kings remember for
23 months Lord silver that stranding two
versus a Kojima cloud-based game I'll
take the cloud-based game please and so
will all them Sony stands playing Xbox
on the DL wow which is all of them yeah
yeah
we got done a taco oh my God VR ain't
popping until Nintendo pull up oh God
[Laughter]
yes I forgot about that you don't
remember when the warehouse caught on
fire it was a small fire only the VR
section burnt
I forgot yeah that was not a good look
you can't be talking with that one I
forgot about that yeah that's a lot you
got one more we got PO with an ammo [ __ ]
not a super chassis
I said to be fair you could just Google
something do you think that uh the dude
that said uh White Cog is literally name
called I've never seen a parole officer
at least I don't have a picture yeah
that's that's free R Kelly's parole
officer
yo shout out to the PO up in here
five dollars it was that we will not be
accepting any Jim Ryan slander he's our
top weekly informant Cog you gotta step
it up to go to the three-piece Smith
yeah I feeding no information to you
brother but salute to you and your
mission
what you trying to do over there
[Music]
so uh yeah that time of the month as I
said October patreon uh to give thanks
to all of our supporters we appreciate
you so much so let's get into it the 10
gift card giveaway goes true
[Music]
working class zero okay work at class
zero absolutely
thank you thank you sir
then we have the 20 gift card Super Chat
gift card 20 gift card giveaway
giving you some chat money
and back
now Luigi
that's your number one fan
yeah
all right that Artis prank giveaway goes
too
basket repair
yeah
TV on Twitch look at these guys salute
see you on Twitch sir he's watching yeah
no doubt so casket repairs thank you to
everyone uh who the winners you know
what it is come see me in uh on Twitter
and DMS and I will get you your stuff
snitching products
as those are limited edition products
yes
so when we finish with that and because
we do have another giveaway if you have
those oh yes
the Ragnarok
hold on a second yeah
not yet not yet oh y'all about to get
away
we'll probably wait till next week we'll
probably wait till next year okay
so look we got a little giveaway while
song was prepping that oh my you know I
forgot to transfer that over so I have
it I got a pro bowl run I love the Pro
Bowl run so yeah you know right now do a
little giveaway a little game coming out
go check this out Peggy 16.
ever had one of those days when you wake
up on an unknown planet after being
frozen for 350 years
dumb question can't wait to find out how
the hell I got here
and just what the hell is going on
so I get involved
maybe I can
I guess the outcome of some things
I soon realize my own decisions have a
huge impact
and it isn't that what it's all about
being in charge of my own destiny
and the destiny of this entire world
is full of secrets hidden Technologies
battles to be fought
stories to be told
my stories
from the last Aura crew
we are back we are back last over crew
up in the enclosed beta y'all go get in
there shout out to our good friends over
there Prime and all that good stuff and
uh yeah check that out man it Souls like
Co-op component you know what I mean and
um yeah action RPGs some good
storytelling aspects and stuff like that
look it's dope yeah shout out to our
good friends at Gold nights shout out
guys good friends at Prime matter
there's a closed beta on Steam right now
you know what I'm saying so you got
until from now into the fourth so I was
gonna put them codes up in there go rest
with that for my PC Lords you know what
I'm saying get ready because they're all
coming in
damn get ready on your mark guess set go
go
if you're part of the
630 something people that's watching and
you didn't put a like in and put a like
in when you walk into my house
but like you need to close beta on that
and then like I said official release
will I believe hold on get you out of
jail so all right so close bet is from
now to October 4th and then official
release is the 13th best played in Co-op
go check that out the last oral crew it
stands for original crew okay the last
original oh geez oh geez
you know who did that whoever made that
is down with all that smoke
eating free free Cheetos what is that
yeah whatever that thing was I when I
was in Cali
all right so we all said something right
yes sir we're good we're good I got the
point that we can finally get going what
did she do so last week's poll results
are in and the people have spoke oh
somebody that cop something hold on
oh that makes them stop stitching that
that's what you get they got they got
the the oh what's the Knights of the
Round shirts they're about to go away
yeah
those is about to be sunset yeah yeah
that is true that is the one where we're
all just in a line yeah they're about to
disappear yeah we have something
replaced in that game they're about to
be gone yeah good good catch catching
that down before it go that was a good
pick on your part yeah those could be
Collector's Editions
forgotten mementos
anyway yeah it ain't coming back okay
they're gonna disappear like the first
10 episodes of IOP
anyway
the recent statements by Microsoft CEO
Satya Nadella in regards to competition
with Sony in the midst of the Activision
Blizzard King deal scruty what do you
think Sony's response should be the
winner of the three-way IOP poll at a
commanding
73 of the vote was the messy Lords I
don't care ask Nintendo how they
surviving without calling to
Bessie coming to that second place was
only 16 of the vote was continued to
talk to Regulators about the
ramification of Call of Duty not having
an adequate deal for PlayStation and
block the deal and it closed last place
actually uh yeah nine percent of the
vote get Microsoft to commit to a
long-term deal regarding Call of Duty
parody or Playstation Lord King your
thoughts sir
Nintendo's showing you how to move in
these streets without moving their lips
apparently
at the memo and know exactly what to do
make good product be fair and people
will purchase Sony is not fair and
apparently that products is not selling
to their crew and they need to support a
Call of Duty I can't it's like at the
end of the day like they didn't say
nothing over the Bethesda purchase they
didn't say nothing over the Activision
Partridge there's a reason because they
stand by the quality of the product sure
you might not like some of Nintendo
games I don't like some Nintendo games
but they know they could sell those
games Sony might be feeling a little bit
okay you know we could sell these
PlayStation exclusives but can they make
the money card makes on our platform
these PlayStation exclusives
they can't they set it from their own
lips they can't they cannot so they're
gonna snitch but Nintendo don't care
because they know they make quality
stuff so they sit there and they sip
their tea like Kermit the frogs again
anyway so that's the poll shout out to
all around
guys apologies yeah for some reason the
way the thing the the codes went into
the chat it kind of it it hyphenated
them where it wasn't supposed to be it's
supposed to be 15 characters per code
I'm just gonna put them all back in
there individually I'm sorry yeah just
let them struggle with it
but it is it is 15 characters per code I
don't know what the heck is no copy of
pizza a lot of dudes to try to copy a
piece and get it done no you got to
manually put it in it gave those people
that are a little bit slower uh
opportunity we like because it is an
issue like when people put codes in the
chat man like because I I I've only
tried to snatch one code I saw on that
like I kid you not by the time it must
have been five seconds it was already
gone oh yeah it's probably good
yeah
doing what I can I'm sorry I apologize
yo you did it the best way you did
I already got that
so we got pulled out the way we gotta
get into these topics attic you are up
first what is going on with these Halo
infinite rumors
yeah so
there you set it up you said yeah I mean
well shout out to Windows Central you
know shout out good friend Chez Corden
and the team over there so I think this
all started initially with an interview
or with Venture beat with certain
Affinity talking about
um the project they potentially were a
shout out to a certain Affinity CEO Paul
Sams he described the range of topics
teasing a large Halo project and that
certainly fits the project Tatanka rumor
because Tatanka was the rumor of code
name of what the Battle Royale was
supposed to be again shot the window
it's not a chance go to the window so
you're doing phenomenal work man a lot
of those guys over there and he said uh
Paul Sands from certain Infinity said
this the biggest thing we're doing
that's public right now for more than
two years now we've been working on Halo
infinite doing something that's very
perspective prescriptive about what we
can't say but we're doing something
unannounced it's something big and new
for the franchise I can't say any more
about it this is our single largest
project of our three projects currently
we have close to 100 developers on that
so that was the initial story that broke
then I believe the gentleman's name is
Sean W from YouTube he dropped them just
keeps getting deeper right here he
dropped a major bombshell about all
these things that are kind of going on
that he's hearing within 343 and one of
the major ones was Unreal Engine five a
potential switch to that and some inner
workers about what's going on so the the
streets are in the bus right about you
know is Halo going to go to Unreal are
they going to go away from slipstream
what's going on I think that was kind of
like the basis of this initial
discussion so I'm gonna let you go since
this is yours you know what I mean when
you have this man
I feel like this is one of those
scenarios where it's like you know
take with a grain of salt but at the
same time just retracted his original
statement saying it wasn't true so
clearly he's hearing something I mean he
Jazz doesn't really do that a whole huh
we gotta Echo sometimes it might Reverb
okay I don't I don't think I heard it so
I don't think it's me you don't hear no
more hello hello
so pretty much you know
the it the engine I feel like is the the
key culprit here I think that's one of
the reasons that they're having a hard
time with content if if you have a
horrible engine and you know I wouldn't
even say horrible just not keep in mind
this is a brand new engine too like it's
not like this is an engine that people
have been using for decades yes this is
the first game it looks like the only
game this blue space engine is going to
be uh responsible making so you know
maybe it was just one of those things
where if this is true they had you know
corporate had like a little meeting with
some uh with some analysts in there they
decided you know maybe it's better for
us to restart than to fix gotcha and you
know I I don't know if you saw on the
leaks too they said that they're
abandoned in the uh the Halo infinite IP
as well and the leaks mention of a Halo
the endless game for those that don't
know obviously apparently the
Cliffhanger ending for people who ended
it there's um
instead of infinite and listening
another way to say infinite
all they're really doing it and it's
kind of it's kind of funny is they're
they're okay Halo Halo endless was going
to be the next expansion let's just
scrap infinite and make that a new game
so I I feel like you know because it was
pushed back they got to go to another
engine you know unreal is a very keep in
mind when you hire people and keep like
all these contractors stuff they have to
learn on the Fly how to use this place
good point like it's not something that
you go in there and just automatically
know how to use I'm sure a lot of the
contractors felt like uh you know dear
if the headlights in their eyes because
they can't understand the concept of
this engine
unreal is is pretty much a universal
engine almost everyone uses it that in
unity and more people use unreal than
anything these days so I I think that's
if this is true that's the better role
because
I feel like if they're able to react
quicker they can make quicker updates
quicker content and I feel like that is
the best case scenario for this now it
is ironic
that when Bonnie Ross steps down a
couple weeks later they're talking about
changing the engine like rumors are
talking about changing the engine so you
know maybe maybe the new the new people
in charge have something to do with this
as well this is what's going on because
if Jazz retracted his statement chances
are this is currently this is this
probably happened in the past couple
months I don't think this is like like a
lot of the time when we get stuff from
the industry it happened months and
months and months ago we're just getting
that info now but I feel like since Jazz
didn't know initially and the fact that
he went because Jess is very choosy in
what he says on Twitter and he came out
there and said none of this is true but
then no no no no I've seen the fact
first yeah at first when he first said
that yeah he didn't know because he
didn't do any information because it
sounded keep in mind there's been very
few times that something like this has
been done if any yes it might be
unprecedented
when Jess saw that same thing with me
you know you see something like that it
is crazy to think that they would just
abandon an engine so your immediate
response would be that's fake that's not
that's not true but then clearly he did
something that night because in the
morning he retracted that statement and
to me
the reason he didn't know is because
it's it's recent it just happened
probably like a month ago a couple weeks
right so that's the reason that you're
seeing the outlay right now and what I
want to know is who over there is
leaking stuff at 343 like there's
because like there's crazy that that
YouTuber like leaked a bunch of stuff
like it was just one or two things
the YouTubers breaking in the 80s don't
say that dude people stitches on this
podcast
apparently I don't run the podcast off
of snitches
but apparently you know dude has been a
a really good solid source for Halo news
a good solid snitches
anyway as if dudes will be running with
a lot of this information we'll be
seeing but hey moving on these snitches
and sizes go ahead and continue
I feel like what you're saying is you're
seeing
stuff being shifted around yeah uh
you're seeing people leave you're seeing
a lot of stuff happening like
drastically at 34th day ironically when
Bonnie Ross steps down so I I don't
think it's a coincidence I think they're
all connected I think who uh the people
who took the reins after a Bonnie left
the cleaning house and you know I that's
good or bad that's to be seen we have to
see more information in the next couple
years on what Halo infinite or Halo
endless looks like but as of right now
it definitely looks like there there was
uh some form of an integral struggle a
struggling happening and maybe Bonnie
Ross kept people around because like not
necessarily you know people got their
favors people are going to ride a dive
for their favors
now that you're seeing these people
leave
maybe that's what happened they were
keeping a lot of uh Bonnie Ross was
keeping a lot of these people around and
now since she is uh stepped down for
medical issues people who took the reins
is like okay they know and protected
yeah yeah I mean it's a very well be I
mean we've seen it before our Studios
right regime changes and when the old
regime you know is out there's a new
regime and a lot of remnants of the
overview team generally don't are not
allowed to usually stay around so it
could be very well true that's what
happened Sean Laden was gone Japan Japan
was about it
y'all he was holding you around you know
y'all was doing nothing now you're gonna
make demos about
shout out to my man Jim bones son Jimmy
bones Jimmy bro anyway so what's up man
where you at man these room is going
around potential engine changes unreal
five mid development endless Battle
Royale where are we at with all these
Ropers I mean I think
I mean I I look at this and with the
moment I remember when we saw slip space
for this first time they announced it
and it's always that thing it's like oh
wow okay they're they're moving forward
they're they're they're evolving right
because they obviously the the engine
previous engine was the the blam engine
whatever
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know when you hear about it
were you here about new engine Tech it's
exciting right but then then you stop
for a minute and you think about what
that entails and I think attic broke it
down perfectly it's like that is the
most difficult thing to do and when
you're incorporating this engine into
the first game that it's going to use
arguably the biggest game that has to
hit and and when you think about the
pipeline that's needed to produce a
service based game in Halo infinite and
you think about it's just a lot of
missteps when you look at it it's like
you it's like you
it seemed like the vision was there and
they were excited to do it and then in
the execution they realized that there
were a lot of barriers to them executing
that the way that that they needed to so
this idea of it possibly getting
sunsetted and going over to Unreal makes
a whole lot of sense a lot of people you
talk about how
yeah having your own engine is
beneficial because it's in-house
everybody that's in-house knows how to
use it they've been trained on it
whatever the case may be you don't have
to pay licensing fees but at the end of
the day unreal is unreal and unreal is
that engine that across the board when
you look at it in terms of tech in terms
of usability in terms of of uh it being
ubiquitous across the industry that's
the one that you really look at like hey
we might as well invest in this because
everyone else is and when you look at
what it's capable of and like addicts
said the key to it is there is so much
turnover in the games industry that you
need people across the board that
understand that yes anybody who comes
into three four three from the outside
has no idea what slip space is has never
used it it's never been outsourced
anywhere you have to first learn how to
use that in order to be and to be
helpful or useful in in doing something
with Halo infinite so for me it's the
right thing to do now sunsetting Halo
infinite
get into
we I think we talked about this when we
were talking about the Bonnie situation
and what that means and sometimes you
know listen you you took a path with
Halo infinite and
if you are not willing to follow that
pass meaning give it the support that it
needs as a service based game continue
to give it that single player support
like you said you were and expand upon
that that that that lore and history in
single player form as well if that is
not what you're willing to do
then
give however many updates you're going
to give to this game leave it alone
couple of seasons whatever the case may
be let it let it die and then go back go
back to the drawing board with the next
one and think about hard what you want
Halo to be if you really do want it to
be this this thing that challenges you
know whatever the fortnites or whatever
the world then now you have an
understanding of what that really takes
and you decide if that's what you want
Halo to be because again Halo has a
certain appeal and I think even with it
being as successful as it was with Halo
infinite and it being good Halo on the
single player and multiplayer side
yeah just people that just don't
gravitate to Halo period right they ask
you this because we're bad about the
sticking what I was thinking I wanted to
ask you to
um so what about the idea that
did we we I think we could all be in
agreement based on the speculation that
day has been struggled with the slip
space engine as far as delivering things
on time right it appears to be for what
we've seen right so the question is now
if the switch to Unreal happens your
mindset is let soft Sunset infinite on
slipstream right because here's the
question the question is Tatanka which
is supposed to be the Battle Royal the
Battle Royale that there's a potential
that may come in with unreal yes because
that's a separate component right and if
it's a separate component in the room
and say that it's not going to be just
integrated into Halo infinite then do
you still transition
Halo infinite over or you just say hard
stop Halo infinite slipstream new game
from that point on I would say hard stop
because when you think about porting a
game from engine to engine that if you
if you're if you're if we're assuming
that the undertaking of just bringing
more content to the slip space engine is
hard right imagine the undertaking of
moving the whole game to unreal right so
it's it's one of those things of like
what if all I gotta do is flip a slip
switch that's what Twitter
do it save as unreal five there you go
if it's easy sure it's not easy I don't
know anything about this I don't know
about this part so I would say no I
would say if if look at look at look at
the landscape now just look at the
landscape if you're telling me that you
can't give me the things you already
promised within that engine after you
thought about it it was like no we can't
do it or we can't do it in a timely
fashion
um then what do you think courting a
game to another engine is going to take
right and is it at this point is it
worth saving that um
if you're not going to necessarily build
upon it right if you're if your idea is
hey Halo infinite is still what it is
it's our 10-year plan right this is the
this is the base this is the core we
have to build on it then then if you're
moving engines then that's the work you
have to do and hey whatever the case may
be I just think that people in the
boardroom looking at this and looking at
the work that it takes to move an engine
over and we'll probably be like you know
what let's cut our losses support this
game for however long we're going to
support it and and move the bulk of the
team over to whatever the next Halo is
on unreal right when you look at around
105 we saw what it could do kind of in
theoretically in a lot of these early
demos that we saw before the consoles
even came out if you go online you see a
bunch of like just artistic renders of
what certain games look in Unreal Engine
Vibe they have one for Halo right right
oh yeah you saw the Unreal Engine five
oh Halo fan-made whatever fan made is
crazy right they had they have them for
Max Payne they have them for GTA and
it's just this is somebody just using
art assets of what that engine can do
not even all the bells and whistles
underneath it
and and you look at that it's like okay
Microsoft can pay the license fees let's
let's build upon this where we know it's
ubiquitous and that's another thing
right if you want it to be this big
thing as Microsoft continues to expand
as Game Pass continues to expand and
Microsoft's tentacles are in more places
you want Halo to be in more places not
for you it only makes sense that you use
an engine like unreal that's kind of
ubiquitous across the industry right so
I just think it makes the most sense uh
where they smoke this fire I believe
this is the case I believe they they're
looking and taking a hard look at
infinite and being like you know what
will cut our losses we learned a lot
from this we're going to support it to
whatever time we're going to support it
and move forward and again and you have
to make the decision of what you want
Halo to be if you want it to be this
humongous thing that tries to compete
with the fortnites of the world and the
war zones of the world then there's a
certain amount of work and effort that
goes into that right and if not it could
just be great Halo and I'm fine with
that too like a great single player
campaign with a suite of amazing maps
that you support for x amount of years
until the next Halo comes out okay and
I'm fine with that too one last question
before I give it the kick so what about
I hear what you say and that makes a lot
of sense I'm not saying it it makes a
lot of sense you just like you know what
cut our losses with this joint this this
engine is just too difficult it's a pain
you know we move on to the new joint
this wasn't part of our you know not the
aubergine that was so quote unquote
blocking us we you know to tell us that
hey we you know stick with it we ain't
like it now we get to do what we want to
do right that's three four three so what
about
hypothetically if they come to I don't
know whether we're going to say stay in
or whoever's running right and say look
we could switch it and it's not as
difficult as we may think we may need
like a year two year if there's a
scenario where you could convert on the
Fly and then still maintain Halo
infinite from a switch but from a switch
over from Swift stream to unreal
keep forged keep the monetization path
do you think it's smarter them to take
that option or do you still think cut
the loss is still that worth it it's
smarter them to take that option if
they're willing to put the effort into
into maintaining it as a service based
game the way people expect you can't be
giving me a a seasoned battle pass that
lasts eight months I can't do that you
just can't do it when you have the
fortnites of the world out there giving
people content upon content like you
have to if if you're able to do that and
you're willing to do the work to do that
you have to be willing to put the work
in to make sure that it it survives as a
service-based game
one battle pass a year ain't good you
can't do it you can't do it so at the
end of the day it's it that is still the
core problem it's like are you able to
support it
yeah
I don't put my pillow here a long time
with the Volari low you know
Laurie doesn't fit where I am so it's
like let's see addict do this I said oh
my arm my arms has been comfortable for
a minute continue
so that's it again the core problem is
Halo infinite as a service based game
the gameplay is there right we already
know the gameplay is there we played it
last week or the week before it's the
fun is there
the question is are you going to put the
effort into continuing to make it a
viable service based game if the answer
to that is no you move on anyway I think
that's it
King this is a very contentious topic
the internet is buzzing I want to know
where to stand with this if it's going
to be an Unreal Engine situation how
does King feel about these rumors
[Laughter]
you know all this all this Jibber Jab
and all this talking I don't like how
Halo Infinity destruction I don't like
the direction I don't like all right
get your guns ready and get in there now
I don't like how to slip space engineers
and it's just preventing me from all
right
oh
get in there now you will see that all
the talk I I I want all you dudes that
with the back biting and
all those uh development house
let me tell you this this is how it goes
right
all your Ducks is in a row all the stuff
that you asked for is there you're gonna
change the slipstream engine you're
gonna change the name you're gonna go to
this way you're gonna go
all the stuff is in your basket right
now
you don't you don't convince the right
people oh you said somebody moving damn
you don't convince the right people you
don't you don't you don't got the right
ears you got people saying yeah that's
right that's right you bad you bad okay
you bad off of stuff that was done
previously okay
so this Forge is all for previously all
right so when whenever that
endless stuff take over whenever you say
oh you know uh you know the slip
straight engine because it was the
hottest sweetest buttest before you know
it's you know it's preventing us okay
go to something easier something that's
in your Warehouse something that's in
your Elbow Room make it look better we
better not see Craig face
Unreal Engine five and I see a Craig if
I see one toe out of place I'm going to
whip
and and that's on me
Unreal Engine game let me tell you okay
so because this is this is the reality
of it right
the reality of it is you blame one
person
so the deflection went up now it's on
the whole studio so this is how you fold
the studio
it ain't no Shield there it ain't no
protection there ain't nobody to put up
there now no okay so now you got the
three people in place to do the three
jobs that y'all needed to do and we're
gonna get the engine out and we got the
engine to Rolling and we go we go change
the music too get a new Orchestra I
don't care what you do but if it's wrong
you are gone
as a whole so you what you idiots did
was put a giant Target on your back they
built for that what if they like this
the Halo snitch said they not though
well you didn't say that and he did he
did cause he snitching he telling
everything you do so you do anything
wrong we're gonna get the information we
already know that ain't like sip space
well you gonna not like underreal engine
five I don't like how the Lumen this
movie yo
I know what it was what was it I know
what it was over here they told them get
the ray tracing working in the slip
space and it didn't work
what did you get the ray tracing down
that was a promise it was like they was
like it's so hard because
um
but you was a programmer though right
yeah but um I had learned on unreal
my expertise is unreal all right
it's gonna be unreal how quick they fire
you
if this joint don't get right so they
better be right I'm sick and tired of
everybody putting up one person I'm sick
and tired of it and now it's good it's
this is a good thing yeah y'all really
gonna Feel the Fire now and I'm gonna
tell you right now I hope y'all watching
I hope you're seeing I hope you're
sitting in the meeting because all you
did was put a talk when you rack you put
a Target on your back so you better
perform you better get up there and get
it done because if this ain't the best
Halo from a story standpoint yes from a
game play standpoint because remember as
much as y'all won't go in on this story
was lit to me yeah
Chief moved
like the best people all the time so
game core gameplay Halo's back like it's
it's not this has nothing that the game
itself because we said it Halo was back
because it was back as a live service
they feel as a life so to provide
additional content is where the failure
is but to slipstream's credit like you
said King the game course right single
player multiplayer strong we can't say
it's not
so why don't they just say instead of
all this BS okay we're going to focus on
the deficiencies of the game that we
have in hand but what if okay in their
defense what if slipstream like fam is
taking us two months to do a co-op
because the slip stress engine the AI
and this this is where I say I'm just
making stuff up no no
I'm literally just please just just to
clarify it's worse than that right so
let's just say to add one map for slip
stream yo dog it's gonna take like six
but by the time we get y'all this guy
what if this engine is really the
problem okay okay and it's the problem
when it's not
when it's not you know everybody in here
know see because I'm one of those people
that like to remove excuses from people
I feel that so when they give up an
excuse you remove it now fly let's see
you wanna see now all the time yeah I'm
gonna see what it's about when this is
not in your way when you don't have this
barrier that you claiming that is a
barrier I want to see what it be I don't
I want I want to see are you going to
release uh stuff in a Cadence that that
is conducive to actual continued
grinding and playing yes and maybe the
reason why the grinding was so egregious
is because they knew it would take a
year yeah
and the thing about development that I
will say everything as a gamer that we
know and we complain about they know
already they know people like yo this
kind of thing we gonna have to survive
right now because we ain't got we can't
build this out fat they know this
developers no it's just that what they
could communicate against all of it
they'll give it back no just real quick
we talk about like it because we're
talking about slip space I guess the
worst thing in the world and that every
single engine goes through these growing
pains this is this first true game even
though it was built off of blam or
whatever it was it it still it's still
its first iteration like when you think
about should you really have used this
engine on the game that needed to hit on
all levels to start off that that goes
to the top go ahead right right
sorry finish no no so my thing is like
because you know you have to think about
it we talk about it like oh it's the
worst whatever at some point unreal was
the worst right at some point Unity
definitely was the worst right but you
look at something like frostbite no no
I'm saying but again it had its growing
pains and it grew into they those
engines
right where it's like I mean again if
you have to take it somebody in the chat
room take it in the back and shoot it
like oh yellow yeah you know you made
the mistake of trying to put this in
engine on your most premier product in
the moment when it needed to shine the
most and you didn't give the engine the
legs that it needed and the time that it
needed to grow and evolve into what it
needs to be so now you're stuck in a
position where you have to go to this if
you're thinking about it you're going to
this third party thing and you're doing
that
um I just because again I feel bad when
we talk about like the engine is the
worst it may be the worst for certain
things right now
the time to grow and evolve obviously
the gameplay is fine right so it's
something about the development pipeline
that's difficult to add contact maybe
maybe it's what I said what maybe it's
the fact that they holding on to the
Past generation and they should have
deaded the past generation and then in
order or just let it be a cloud-based
thing for them
I just think my thing is I'm sick of all
excuses I'm sick this is being this and
that is being that good I'm happy now
I'm happy now that you don't got no
excuses and you lose do your thing the
moment it come up stank I'm going to
break you over a a bed of colds yeah
trust me you're going to get this work
because I felt the work was unjustified
for uh individual and I'm going to
continue to stand on that square and if
you do not come in Spades Paul you are
roasted and you will continue to be
roasted by me because I've until until
somebody step up and be like nah you
know it was a cool
until it comes up yo it was a cool I can
respect that we see that all constantly
in all regimes is a coup is a type of
situation fine now that you got you in
charge President Day El Presidente now
you gotta lower the food to the taxes
for everybody you better do better than
the last president that's all I'm saying
I think
that you saw another company handle this
better actually work under Microsoft
who's the Coalition they saw something
like Unreal Engine five and they're like
look we're very familiar with unreal but
we're not a hundred percent with Unreal
Engine five so let's make a smaller
title to get ready to take advantage and
then move on from that and then work on
gear six but I don't know why they they
made a new engine and they're like
they're like you guys are going out
there with our flagships
because like Coalition you say that's a
great point is doing it right they're
gonna give a smaller title the unreal
five tests and then the bigger title
most likely gears we would assume right
would be the unreal five now we
comfortable we already got one game on
the unreal five of the belt so what if
oppose it back to y'all what if tataka
AKA Battle Royale is the Unreal Engine 5
test
before Halo endless or whatever they
call it
works 100.
but it's just like at that point the
damage has been done it's like it's
gonna take more than just showing me one
good incident that you've made something
solid you got to show me multiple at
this point because you've had years of
hitting under the back what if this what
if it's the greatest it's gonna have to
be like an apex Legend [ __ ] yeah like
because the target the notes stay they
targeting the king crew they want King
in his son they what the [ __ ] but but
then you know what you know what people
want to say that okay but you know what
people are going to say that that's not
three four three that's another Studio
what's the difference because 343 is not
making that game five okay
the thing that must hit the thing that
must be let's let's do it on some stuff
that we don't know about but they've
been working on it and if it go bad and
uh oh certain affinity
and certain Affinity is kind of like a
third party thing and then you're gonna
point over and say nah that wasn't three
points that's what I'm saying that is
an Infinity Run certain of anyone they
set you up as a doctor yeah
they're excited you know what you know
what's gonna happen Pete I can already
say the first thing I'm gonna see is
people like man certain affinities the
handle the Halo IP like what are we
doing at this yeah but if you go bad for
them they're gonna be like certain
Affinity should never touch another Halo
no no you know no no King if it goes bad
for them 20 bucks 343 gets to gets the
job the smoke yeah certain Affinity
won't even get to smoke
for three
like certain Infinities never worked on
Halo yeah
they know Halo I'm not saying they don't
know
probably better than anybody Anthony
right now
I'm just telling you from from uh from
uh you know perception thing
they have to hit that out of the park
there's no offense butts about it and if
they don't
three four three is gonna naturally get
to smoke because of the Halo title for
sure and it's another thing like we have
to stop and think about like the reasons
why Halo isn't necessarily appealing to
the the Battle Royale crowd the younger
crowd that's playing these fortnights or
whatever it is is Haven feels different
haters a heavier game right so how do
you translate Halo gameplay Arena based
gameplay to what the expectations are of
a battle royale today and does that work
very carefully yeah we'll see they can
do it they can do it yeah let me jump in
this this is funny uh This Thread it's
like I'll be wanting to move on from
talking about it but it keeps coming
back you know it keep coming back it's
that snitch
and we got to stop him you know it would
be amazing but like I would say
there's obviously been bad news with
Microsoft but Halo's always been front
center yeah I don't know for sure
wouldn't it be nice to get rid of this
stigma with Halo listen it's just like I
know that Microsoft low-key like they
just over like we gotta do something man
like we can't keep just keep doing this
over and over again that's what I was
just about to say this definition of
insanity is doing the same things
expected different results my thing is
this this if it is true
would be the most unprecedented thing I
have ever seen I've never seen a game
switch engine mid cycle while it's still
going on you know I mean so
look there's one part of me that's like
yo I love the fact that Microsoft is if
this is true willing to not give up or
Halo and basically look at what the real
problem is
and if it is slip stream
and they go okay this is the reason why
we can't execute this is the main source
of frustration we did the Telemetry we
did the analytics if we switch over and
here's a small you know demo
representation of how things can look
and a pipeline can look with Unreal
Engine I understand that now the other
thing that I have to think that it does
feel a little true
is we shout out the Lord's gaming.net we
gotta plug the home team
you know we definitely put out there as
far as what we heard in reference to the
David Burger firing which no one was
talking about right and that is the lead
of the slip Street split space agent so
if he is removed right from now right
because jobs no longer necessary
clearly I would it's safe to assume that
they are at least thinking about going
another Direction well they probably did
it already or they've done it already I
think it's already been so now the
question comes down is the
implementation because if it is as bad
as we are hearing with this then that's
giving me Anthem and Frostbite Vibes and
we remember the problem when we'll shout
out to Jesus investigate report the
issue came down to the the smallest of
things with such a chore to get done in
Anthem meetings and all they would have
and stuff would get that sort of
question is maybe this is reason why
simple things that we think are simple
like Co-op things that we think the
simple like forwards things that we
think are simple like split screen which
they promised
didn't happen then you could also go
split free and the thought process
initially be like yo we have our own
proprietary engine right yeah we get to
do it how we want to do it and let's be
real you save money on the license fees
you don't have to license out to a
Unreal Engine or whatever whatever but
now
I'm also thinking about what attic said
it was Salsa which is
we know there are a ton of contractors
there there are a ton and I made a good
point like if you come to work
and you can have all experience in the
world in unity and and Unreal Engine
these kind of world-renowned tools to
solve sport which have been built up
over years you know to experience over
you even if Unreal Engine 5 is new
there's a core Foundation of Unreal
Engine that you can kind of Base your
knowledge and your skill set okay I can
work around this I can learn this kind
of thing you know what I mean so I think
that is to their advantage if they're
looking at the bigger play the question
to me is
I always felt it was weird
it's what is it
almost a year that no DLC for this game
no DLC for this game like a very light
multiplayer every light like like no
real content expansion everything is
just like just the smallest the little
list of things that we saw when this
season got extended and we saw what that
was we was like oh that's not really the
content fam so to me that points that yo
that engine is giving them problem and
then maybe they cut bait from the
10-year plan right and maybe it's what's
opposite maybe they say to themselves
look
we do the test bed is Tatanka right
we bring that out that's Unreal Engine
see how that goes get a thing and then
the live team maybe just ride out like I
saw was saying I at that big okay I
don't even think it's a test bed I think
they're like we're off this thing we're
off there's no air fan spots about it
and here's the thing too because it's
like I'm dick I'm mixed though with the
long-term investment because part of me
is like do they really that's a lot of
money for Hillary infinite like that as
far as the money right and I know
because I know Forge was supposed to be
about it because phones look Fire Let's
be clean Forge look fire so part of it
was like yo I know they probably
counting on that get the little
monetization model get people to make
stuff you can eat off of that and baby
that was one of the stressful slipstream
that they saw long term but then if they
like yo we can't even get content out
fast enough we can't even implement this
thing to go live we having all these
type of issues but if we you know if
someone your man come in with the demo
and be like but if we put it on 305 like
the cool the cooler can't call them the
cool team if the cool team is like Yo
dude they're cool
none of this would have happened man we
told you yeah you know the sad part too
man this engine probably because uh I'm
not like I I disagree with some a little
bit that I do feel like Halo is the
perfect game to be against as a service
if it's correctly implemented okay and
it's just like the sad part is just like
they definitely had a formula that they
could have done they could have bring
back the bubble shield from Halo 4. they
could have done so much
to kids point though
it better be the deliverables better hit
without real engine after all this
switching if it better be you because of
this switch now the content could come
on top yeah Ray tracing better be in
there four player co-op better be in
there or everything that ain't in here
better be in a better show okay okay got
it what happens if it isn't a hit what
what goes then
Halo do they just take do they just take
Halo away from three four three yes
um
if I think let three four three make
something else like just just put Halo
on the shelf or if I give him a breather
man give him a breather big battle
royale being bad would be the Oh you
mean Battle Royale
okay okay yeah no no if yeah I mean I
mean that speaks for itself right I mean
if if it switches over with a new
release let's call let's say it's a new
game Halo endless after tataka right
after the battle royale
and the new game comes out it's other
Unreal Engine five and there's still
content droughts and there's still
issues or they're gonna get the smoke of
course yeah it's a no-brainer I got no
choice but the full attempt yeah but
I will say the people that's involved
um what's his man what's his band name
Pierre Heintz
saved Master Chief collection from the
from the rubble you know what I'm saying
stating in a creative position of
control and the fact that that he got it
overstating and that means they have a
lot of faith a lot of faith yeah yeah I
don't think stating I'm be honest I
don't know this thing even one of them
yeah he probably didn't want it but he
was probably a contender in the room
probably that they were considering all
I will say the team that they have
constructed though is a serious team not
a nice little Dream Team you better not
come home
remember remember
they got the best of the best the
brightest of the brightest and they lost
if you lose
you will get excoriated you better come
home with nothing better than the gold
son the goals nothing less than goldfish
that's all I got on this one unless
y'all got anything else no all right
good damn thing tired of that
snitching man just let them work listen
man things coming out man anyway so we
got a super chats yeah hold on second
there's a couple that just popped in
we got 700 people and only 300 likes
yeah
your feet yes please you know one thing
I want to like really appreciate is like
I know we have a lot of sports going
people I'm not one of them but it's like
I appreciate you guys watching this
instead of uh foosballs
if you think they don't have yeah
my team start off looking man every year
if the deal does not happen to y'all
think that Activision will ever do
another marketing deal with Sony
um
I don't know I don't because because
apparently they want it bad like maybe a
millionaires Well here here's the thing
like if if they did
destroyed this deal I do think it would
impact their relationship with
Activision for a while at least until
the people that's in lead of Activision
right now step down because we've seen
it in this industry where people's
personal vendettas definitely carry past
business yeah yeah we've seen it for
sure and if it doesn't go through think
about all of the stuff that they talked
about like like Bobby kotik probably
doesn't go anywhere right
things would be not pretty at Activision
Blizzard but I can tell you this I can
give you a scenario what that would
happen being a it's not you know
Activision itself it's the shareholders
all the shareholders were gone and it
would take their abundance of wealth and
it would go by a whole bunch of shares
and Sony and they didn't they will in
turn take all those shares Galvanize
them and all sell them to Microsoft
where Microsoft will have a 51 stake in
the company and that's how a hostile
he started that conversation with logic
yeah
so exactly and this is what they do they
sell they shares to Microsoft get their
money that they were losing that they
lost because somebody over there wanted
to come over there and snitch and do all
these things and not supposed to but
what happens now we buy them then once
you buy them then we have them shut up
in the corner like they did that company
that told you that this system was
messing up the game it wasn't them and
then they quiet them and let us go
through with the deal for real thank you
for uh cost to take over one-on-one
the knife to the CEOs
then we got Michael Mooney by proud to
be chat Microsoft needs its game
engineering teams to build an in-house
rival to Unreal Engine no no I mean they
don't I mean they've already started
that the first time yeah so you know
we'll see what happens today
there we go yeah baby
baby
part of my Sunday routine special shout
out to God oh absolutely that's the
homie man got the DM salute Brothers
welcome to the realm you already know
wait a second yeah
[Laughter]
we got flame remember for one year two
dollars take your Halo infinite Outback
like Old Yeller please
then we got J1 five dollar Super Chat
greetings Lords all this engine talk
made me realize how many Xbox games
we'll be using on row five Coalition
Coalition has a lot of coaching to do
yes
in five games
even though they're not using all the
assets and stuff yet not yet yeah yeah
yeah then we got Hollywood rules five
dollars chat due to my football Sunday
obligations can't watch live or wanted
to show support to my video game cousins
get them King happy ILP Sunday salute uh
Hollywood rules multiple screens
multiple screens so unique and you can
watch live go slow then we had the Xbox
One old feature snap and yeah yeah
so now you can't snap yeah I remember
that I did like that feature then we got
Michael Mooney five Pro Super Chat Daisy
started to switch from armor to infusion
during 2014 with 3 million Pairs and
it's still ongoing there you go so it's
not an easy thing 2014. yeah
and let me see what else I think we
jumped a little bit hold on a second
nope we're good
we are good no doubt let's get into the
next joint this is mine let me set it up
real quick so stay here
um shout out to uh Phil luminous of
bloody shoes gangs
[Laughter]
I know you could man
I know this is
it I was definitely teasing you to call
him Phil Lewis oh you're oh okay
you don't remember I remember when he
came out on stage your car was gone
he was talking strong and I was like oh
that energy that's what I was born
with this with the red blood sugar so
yeah
blood all up in the snow yeah yeah so
Australia we gotta talk about it um
shout out to the team over there but uh
there was a big big announcement this
week so this comes from Phil Harrison
luminous himself uh a few years ago we
launched a consumer gaming service
Stadium while stadiums approached
streaming get streaming games because
someone was built on strong technology
it hasn't gained attraction with users
that we expected so we made the
difficult decision to begin winding down
our stadia streaming service we're
grateful to the dedicated state Area
players that have been with us from the
start we will be refunding state of your
Hardware purchases made through the
Google store and all games and add-on
content purchases made through the
stadium store players will continue to
have their games library and play
through January 18 2023 so they can
complete final play sessions we expect
we expect to have the majority of
refunds completed by mid-January 2023 we
have more details players on this
processor they finalize the statement by
that power stadium has proven at scales
that it transcends gaming we see clear
opportunities to apply this technology
across other parts of Google like
YouTube Google Play and augmented
reality and we we remain deeply
committed to gaming
you're stupid invested new tools
and all you hear is this
technology we remain deeply committed to
gaming and we will continue to invest in
new tools Technologies and platforms
that power to suggest success of
developers industry Partners Cloud
customers and creators so that was the
announcement that went out that broke
the internet that stadia is shutting
down yes
[Laughter]
stupid so then there was some of the
additional news and additional context
to this that I want to bring forward
which is as king would say
Phil luminous some potential snitching
against kingwoods so um all right so
pretty much uh Bethesda Google stadiums
Phil Harris reports that Microsoft's
acquisition of Bethesda played a role in
shutting stadia Studios down so he says
the past Thursday there was a q a with
staff regarding the decision on why they
shut down stadia's development teams
this is a shout out to Kotaku reporting
it he said while Harrison was said to be
very Coy regarding the reasons for the
decision one specific thing he mentioned
was Microsoft's ongoing acquisition of
zenimax which includes Bethesda ID
software machine games and other
subsidiaries he how Microsoft but that's
the acquisition forced them into wasn't
explained but but Harrison is reported
to have said that Microsoft's
acquisition and its ongoing buying spree
of other Studios was a factor in
Stadium's decision kataku didn't provide
any further context for horizon or
Harrison's response and he didn't get a
direct quote but quote but if Paris was
really said that it must have been
important shot the game's rant which I'm
reading that from right there so this is
the big one this is the big one so I got
to bring it to the realm I'll have a lot
of things to say at the end but um yeah
what do you guys feel stadia is done and
they Phil Harrison is
blaming Microsoft's acquisition of
bethesda's one of the key factors hey
what do you feel about this it's
absolutely absurd like it's like you
um stadia felt because they didn't take
the industry seriously they thought they
can come here with money and push their
way through and it's just like no like
you you can't do that they should have
had exclusive content for their platform
their streaming platform out the gate
they didn't have that they bought
Studios after they launched and thought
people were going to wait around two
years to wait for the games and not only
Midway through those games being made
they shut them down so it's just like no
the only people you have to blame for
Google stadia shutting down is if Google
studies people that are running it
looked at the mirror that's the only
thing for that it has nothing to do with
Microsoft it has enough say if you want
to use that same concept what why Why
didn't it go with tencent but Sony just
bought Sony just bought Bungie and that
was a key player with them for a minute
when they had all the stuff go to
Stadium why was it that energy shot
towards them you know what king I
wouldn't be surprised at Jim Ryan so
you're like let's let's make joints oh
are you implying
here's the thing here's the thing it
makes no sense to why it's just
Microsoft's fault if tencent has
probably bought way more than Microsoft
has done and if tencent hasn't bought it
they've invested heavily into it it
makes no sense to go on and publicly
blame one person one company first stuff
that multiple companies are buying to
well I think they did the math Sony's
bought like nine Studios I mean in
Brazil when the first level of stitching
went down the first novel
who had nothing negative to say about
the acquisition potential acquisition of
Activision Blizzard cake which is a
larger deal but now that the news came
out that they are shutting down we're
hearing new Rumblings of them
potentially saying that Bethesda was the
reason so are you saying that are you
applying that this is some contradictory
stuff here what's going on I think what
this is is this is we don't want to put
blame on people that we feel were that's
beneath us you know they they might
what's going to look more bad for Google
for Google to come out and say you know
Microsoft's someone that could that has
just as much money of us just as much
power and influence they stopped us for
doing like yeah Sony I know they're way
smaller than us but they they they they
bullying us to oh Activision they didn't
sell to us we tried like there's
multiple scenarios to the reason Google
say these in it and I honestly feel like
they they took a shot at the the biggest
piece on the board that they felt like
they could to make it make more sense
because how is Google going to come out
openly and say look they bought Bethesda
so we was already being real shaky so
it's just like okay so Microsoft outbids
you and that's why you're upset over
it's easier to say that to come out and
say the industry bullied us out we they
bullied us out we couldn't do it anymore
shout out to James he said a snitch in
the hand is worth it
that was hilarious sir I am sorry
continue so that that's what I feel is
going on I feel like they
they just they didn't take the industry
as seriously as they should have and by
the time they decided to take it it was
just too it was too late they they look
it's okay you don't feel but that's the
block but that's what was was really
influential with shutting them down I'm
just curious why people that why someone
like Google that has the money to
compete with Microsoft in these deals
they're right they're mad because they
got outbid I bet you if you had people
in the room Google had a bid too and
when they lost the bid for Bethesda
they're like we out we out like because
at the end of the
daylight if you think about it and do a
timeline I bet you if you actually went
there and looked at looked at the how
everything transpired it wasn't too long
after Bethesda that they started closing
first party Studios
look like they got mad because the
industry bullied them like Google is
used to coming in and failing horribly
every time
they have a failed history
they have a horrible track record I was
about to say something right
careful but uh yeah so you're implying
that they have a history of because I'm
starting to see this talk addict I don't
know if you saw that like yeah like you
know because it is we they have to be
very concerned about Microsoft in the
future and now someone who was no didn't
have anything to say in Brazil
okay what they should have said what
else AKA what they should have said is
we came in this industry and we forgot
about Micah Microsoft wouldn't invest in
like they was now we came into this
industry and we thought we could outbid
everybody you know what's going to be
able to outbid us but then we realized
that Phil Dominus Maximus Spencer has
convinced Microsoft to open the bank
account for everything and now we no
longer can outbid everyone that
Microsoft's outbitting everything we do
that that's my point just like I don't
mind that you're trying to say that you
know with the consolidation in the
industry that that's an issue and you
felt like you couldn't compete it's one
thing to sit there and say a statement
like that and bring up a list of names
it's another thing to go out and say
it's specifically one individual company
doing it when the entire industry is
doing it it's just like it to me it felt
like if I can't buy the people I want
because these people come over there and
buy it's like being in a bidding war
like when you're sitting there in
someone's auctioning something off every
time they raise their hand Microsoft's
like
that's what we got that's all man you
know stadia you know streaming you were
one of the furly adopters if I believe
you're getting this money back you keep
getting his money back
so so this is my history we stayed here
right I got that I got that beta invite
right when it was called project stream
right yes and you get the beta in by you
go in you got to make sure you have the
right connection right so I had gigabit
connections so there's no issue and they
give you AC Odyssey to play It's funny
because that's where I played as alexios
and it was not pleased so I went and
played AC Odyssey and yo like yeah I was
like whoa attack was five can't deny it
was beautiful it played beautifully I
was like okay project extreme let's go
but again
you when they when they unveiled it at
stadia and they talked about everything
was gravy until they uh until they said
yeah the game's gonna cost 60 dollars a
pop for something that lives in the
cloud it will never ever even remotely
be yours that the potential business
strategy that they implied was part of
their devil
Parts
it was the absolute it's so funny when
Layman like us can see it a mile away
and the people that come up with this
have no idea or or it's just that the
hubris is so high that they're like nah
you're gonna you're gonna go for this
and this is it and they did say no more
console game this is the future at all
they were like look at all terrified
remember what flocks was the thing
exactly and they had the Xbox one slide
and the PlayStation 4 we got double the
power we're double the power the flops
in the cloud what we do
but then you can't see then you have to
you have to look at who's promoting it
right and then we we get it to to feel
luminous right Phil luminous has a track
record of a lot of a lot of grand
expectation a lot of a lot of blow
reading about things that are in theory
and
are you implying that Phil luminous has
a track record of he has a track record
of you know just he has a lot of great
aspirations and what happens is that in
practice theory they're fantastic in
practice things don't usually work out
and where are these places so do we know
uh anybody anybody remember having to
get a second job Playstation three he
was part of that yeah you know then you
remember in programs oh yeah remember
those guys he was on somebody Xbox One
launched he can't even remember Xbox one
he was fine he was there
um it's just you know I pride myself on
you know I don't know anything I don't
really talk I don't know you know I
don't I don't have some of the
connections that people have like I just
go by what what said in the news and try
to you know deduce things that have
happened you know I don't I don't have
any other in from nothing I don't know
anything so
when I heard that he pointed the finger
at Microsoft and if it does acquisition
I said step back for a minute okay
where is his thinking here where is this
coming from
and when I tell you that I could not
come up with one valid logical reason
why you would point to Microsoft they
bought Bethesda so we can't do our own
thing
how
where does this come from that's what
logic does it make that I can't do my
own thing because they went over there
and did something else
none of it makes sense there's no
logical Aid to being deceived they
thought that we can't work
set the lights off that's it shut it
down y'all that's it they bought that
that's over
[Music]
it is it is bad it's baffling at it it's
baffling that that he would make a
statement like that but if you look at
his track record he is known for making
statements like this that it just out of
left field and it's it's all because I
feel like he is when we call him
luminous because he is he does have that
that luminaries where it's like the
vision but it's always you know you look
at Peter molyneux he's like I remember
he was like in Fable you're gonna plant
this tree and the tree gonna come back
to the end the tree is going to be bro I
still remember projects I was like me
and kick was like yo that's that's
that's evil how they doing that [ __ ]
and when you look at people right when
you look at Peter Molly knew right you
you feel like he doesn't have that he
doesn't have bad intentions with that he
really in his heart feels possible it's
gonna be and then the reality sort of
brings them down to earth when you look
at Phil Phil Harris
look at Bill Harrison he's a straight up
businessman yes
in your heart of hearts you feel like he
knows better
no in your heart of hearts you know like
he knows better and he still lies to you
with a big grin in his face that's the
way it feels and the way it comes off
um when when this so it's been sort of
said that the information we got
about the shutdown happened nearly
simultaneously to when the team's
working at Stadium got the information
how does that happen wow like it
everything that it feels like comes out
of his mouth is disingenuous and that
and that's the bad thing about it and
the fact is that we talked last week
about you know the Logitech handheld and
how certain things have to just happen
in order for other things to be
successful and certain things just need
to be in the market and die so that
other things can be propped up that are
better and improve upon the mistakes
that were made Stadium everything about
Stadium on the back end seemed great yes
and it was literally the pricing model
that killed them and when they pivoted
it was too late already it was too late
for anyone to care so again it's a
product that existed so that other
things could rise and shine and take its
place
um you know much in the same vein of an
on live or whatever it was but the
problem with online was that it was a it
was a product before its time this is a
product that could have hit in the right
way if they had not had hubris about it
and I and I think it's full hubris when
you look at again when you look at Phil
Harrison's sort of track record all the
things that he was sort of a part of
failed or had negative reactions to them
because of hubris because of this this
implied sort of this don't tell us you
don't we don't care what you want we're
telling you what you want no doubt
production no native Play No native play
this is it and this is it this is the
way this is it and to be fair a lot of
things they talked about about like you
would never be able to see a multi we'll
have a multiplayer game with thousands
of players and and things of that nature
and all things that you couldn't
possibly imagine on a console So in
theory a lot of this stuff seemed
exciting I'm like well if there's
anybody with the infrastructure besides
Microsoft to pull this off it would be
them yeah you know what's funny though
so you talking about all this talking
about all that man are they lucky they
ain't getting sued class action lawsuit
like yeah
full of money they're making right in
the way that they can which is giving
back everything that they sold through
the Google Play Store right they also so
but again they were they were sort of
pop-up shops and Best Buys and stuff
like that so they sold Hardware outside
of it I don't know how significant and
right so it it's one of those things
where they're doing the best they can
with Amir culpa with the things they
have control over which is the Google
Play Store right so that that and you
don't have to give back the stuff so you
can keep it it's just gonna be worthless
not that it wasn't me not that it was
worth it had any worth at this point but
um so for me you know a stadium we
hardly knew yeah um I think I think it's
claim to fame was that uh it was the
only working version of cyberpunk where
cyberpunk was broken
um and yeah listen man I just I can't
believe that every person on this panel
the moment they saw the pricing
structure they said as a rap game and
they could not see that it's it just
feels like I I don't know man I I just
don't I don't understand how these
meetings work out where someone with
such a sort of a vision that's out there
doesn't get grounded by people who see
the forest for the trees it just feels
super weird because they should have
known better but they should have known
better in a million other cases too with
other products again they don't have the
best track record that's Google so uh
anybody taking bets on how long it takes
before Phil Harrison is gone I say less
than six months these problems are
already gone yeah you just don't know a
game players might be he just left yeah
I don't know if it's a lot of homes for
him right now but anyways uh kid man
bands
why you got the fraud to learn up I told
each and every last one of y'all with
that stadia crap
it was a matter of time before it was a
wrap
yes yes another prediction from the King
you did call this
but I think he's the only one that
called it before the price
he saw his shoes
red sneakers I said oh that's that guy
he's not know that dude remember that
dude and you know what I'm not gonna say
feel them I'm not gonna say his first
name no more his name is Mr Harrison
not to be confused with the real feel
because he was telling me you know real
feel like dudes was telling me before I
don't feel no no we're not gonna
associate that dude with the real feel
this is Mr Harrison the Destroyer
every way he goes he lays waste and I
don't know how he keeps getting jobs
from place to places
when you've been in the industry that
long and you've made the friends that
that man has made a lot of the time like
yeah it doesn't matter what you know it
matters who you know the places where it
matters it's who's his frat brothers
where your frat brothers is in position
of power they put you in bro they let go
that's that's Mr Harris and the
Destroyer bring them on in let them let
them sink Sony for a whole generation
let him go over to Xbox One and do his
destructive Nation bring him over the
stadium to fold up to 10. and push him
to Extinction
this is the best this is the absolute
best I am so happy I remember going in
it on Brad and Brad was like oh stadia
is better than Xbox cloud and yeah
remember we was oh it's gonna destroy
Game Pass look at you now
I love every last party I don't care
because I hold on to old grudges I'm
Petty like that
you're like yeah I can't wait I'll wait
until the very last and and then I just
jump in and say surprise remember me
and this is it this is it right here so
the fact that your boy said and
everybody's trying to figure out
where did all this come from first of
all kataku we already know if there's
anything negative about Microsoft your
face is going to be there so again you
if if he would have yelled out Sony we
would have never heard you say a word
you would have never printed it you
would have never tweeted it you would
have never said anything about it but
being that Microsoft name came up here
comes the taco hold on I gotta be the
first to tweet that out
this one's for you but this is yours you
Earnest this is your prize this is it
you step right into my trap yo addict
could you hit him with that trap card
for me please
my I had different sounds in King does
like his thing first one of yours King
oh you talk about this one yeah yeah I I
have different ones than those I could
press them just they gotta show me how
to use that yeah
all right so no we don't no we don't
that's our thing who jumped on this and
thought this was a moment that this dude
was snitching the only reason why he
said anything about Microsoft is because
the last time he got a severance check
was from Microsoft so when he got the
established check and he came through he
was like
the last dude that he was with that this
happened to him was with Microsoft so
you're gonna say oh it was this deal
that did it no
Google messed up on Google Glass Google
Google has a huge track record of of
bringing stuff to the market and never
supporting it action so just like addict
said they was probably in the meeting
doing the bidding and stuff like that
and Google threw up uh 10 billion is
good yeah yeah buddy and Microsoft
throws out 70 billion you're like what
if they playing
so uh Mr Harrison
told them oh don't worry about Microsoft
they don't ever bid on nothing like that
we got this in the back that 10 billion
should be good and they look over at
Harrison like bruh who said they wasn't
bidding bidding but Phil Dominus Maximus
are really expensive
with the word from Young Odin the bag is
good B like this is gonna happen this
way so yeah let's let's blame it on
these dudes I know what really happened
what happened
yeah man Jimmy bones went over there and
was like yo
are you implying that two companies are
in cahoots so I'm just saying collusion
happens every day B and he said yo um
being at you out the door I might got a
soft place for you to land
and all I need you to do is when you
going forward
I like this game not like this I need
you to say
who held you back like who did this to
you
he talks is that talk to him
and with a T I just I just you know wait
wait wait did y'all check him before he
came here
based on your theory well you know Jimmy
bones drop move up on dudes like dudes
would be sitting there talking yo yes I
brought a coffee cake yo what's up B oh
Jimmy what's up man I heard that you got
some information might be necessary
um yeah um yeah let's talk in my office
soundproof rules were recorded only for
him
later so all of a sudden now Microsoft
is the culprit for the dudes that did it
to themselves you shot yourself in the
foot but Microsoft was hunting in the
woods down the block Microsoft shot me
nah you shot yourself you came out with
a wrong pricing model and you didn't bid
properly and you hired the wrong dude
with the red shoes so you gonna blame
Microsoft for something that was
self-inflicted all your injuries are
self-inflicted and you bled out you bled
out on your own on the floor so you mad
that you got to give back all the money
from the ill-gotten games you lied to
people now you got to get back to cash
and they not even giving back all the
cash they just giving the cash back from
those few people that said imma buy from
Google themselves not everybody else
that uh purchased from Best Buy from PC
Richards that purchased from Amazon and
anywhere else no no no no and this is
the best part
January 2023 we just when we shut the
lights out on you we're gonna let you
play your games and odyssey
you just bought a season pass for
Destiny but you got to 2023
he told you at least they told you when
they turning off your digital games that
you don't own but it was the future and
you had nothing to worry about obviously
the warrior starts now so what do you
feel about you know obviously the Google
obviously the statement that they made
with Phil I'll be with Mr Harrison
excuse me Mr Harrison
um and what do you feel about the the
coinciding September 8th um shout out to
uh Sony uh secret Alpha and they said uh
Sony interactive had Jim Ryan met with
European Commission on September 18 flew
out to the headquarters of Brussels
according to this um Google Now is also
said to have worried about the worries
about the transaction activation and has
voiced its concern regular so
according to you
this would constitute as two companies
snitching on Microsoft how do you feel
about this well we already know one is
addicted to snitching and he infected
the other dude
he has an addiction to the snitching he
flew out to Brussels ain't nobody call
him
we got a Dude down at the gate who Jimmy
bones like what what is Jimmy doing here
this week nah he brought Google with him
he said he's doing too much about flying
out because they asked me he flew out he
did ask him to come out they didn't ask
him for anything Jimmy just did with
information knocking on the door I got
information
um
it affected them too and we don't want
to end up like Google because Google is
out like now do you see how ill this
happened it could hurt us I said where
her Google poor Google
Mr Harrison and Jim danced with Ryan
he's coming out coming out of that that
therapy they have because they got
outbid by Microsoft and they just
crossed eyes off each other
[Laughter]
is out of control he's Unstoppable he's
addicted to snitching he's gonna have to
go to snitching Anonymous this dude just
literally snitches for no reason I'm
outside the store and say oh I forgot to
give you a penny why are you snitching
on yourself
he helped that's right yeah baby baby
you got people in the building he walked
up in there and he's like he was sitting
there it's like it's like the brother he
had at College they they taking
everything from me man
Jimmy The Inside Man
Tribe Called Quest said we're on the
world
[Laughter]
the moment Jim Ryan like he's watching
the news and then okay the the American
ones it seems like they're they're with
the deal tiffy's like okay what about UK
I don't know I'm going over there
it's like the moment they're they're the
the moment that in particular part of
the world is looking at I I bet you if
we would back he was in Brazil like six
months ago he was in Egypt
I heard they heard they got a council
over here too
[Laughter]
he just walked up there he sits down and
he's like well what can I do for you Jim
he's like I got two truck foods for the
PlayStation
I bring great news
Microsoft is out here hurting everybody
hey hey and then and then he imagine
like the like Jim's about to leave the
Pharaoh goes in his room he opens his
door and there's an Xbox series
[Laughter]
this is hilarious oh yeah I mean like so
I said um obviously I was part of the
the tech I was in the stadium build you
know what I mean when they were early
with it you know what I'm saying hey
look the tech was fine the tech was
fired you know what I'm saying no
latency you had the 4K the 60 frames
right you know the resolution bumps and
all that and I remember the attic you
know the hustle at the time instead his
defense because there was no cheating
clothes platform you could get your
lighthouse on over there baby you go to
the lighthouse over there the match back
it was a bit slow because obviously the
playing pool was really low but they had
high npt tech and I will say like I have
to play things you went over there
because of the cheaters because that
that competition is as good as it was I
ain't gonna lie like look man I'm trying
to get to the lighthouse anyway I could
and people told me about that only thing
is no recipes I mean pour it out for my
homie Stadium time his whole channel is
based on that and oh my goodness he's a
huge Stadium fan he's a huge Destiny guy
I gotta reach out to him see how he's
doing we had him on the last word shot
the stadium time good content creator
but um yeah I mean at the end of the day
look
solve is right I remember that press
conference I guess that's why I was
instigated with kids they were popping
off they were super ambitious they was
like the consoles are dead this is the
way right again I said they were super
lying I mean they were popping off they
were telling people they were like we're
more powerful with this and the mistakes
that I started to see initially was
no option for Native play it was
streaming or bust and they didn't care
it was get down or lay down this is how
we doing it right so I was number one so
to me it's like okay I hear this dudes
and I wakes off 100 like
you gotta explain to me
how
Bethesda the sole acquisition of xenomax
destroys your entire business model that
the sole acquisition of Microsoft doing
this it just folded you there was
nothing you can do right so I look at it
like I said we talked about the first
mistake with the with the low streaming
I mean an old native gaming right then
we talk about let's come on we got to be
real about this software lineup y'all
remember that lineup there was no talk
there was no software a lot like the
only big substantial thing I remember
was like Destiny I think was Shadow keep
at the time they give you that you know
cyberpunk then the other thing is you
pay the subscription service
for them stadia Pro
you ain't getting no games you will
literally get one maybe one game a month
right then the real benefit of the
service was that you were paying for the
resolution and 4K that's what she was
paying for you were paying because you
had this plethora of games that you're
going to get and it took a while for
them even to get that so that was
mistake number two then number three is
like King said we not gonna act like you
ain't got the worst track record with
launching product services and all them
theoretically die I mean there's a site
called Google graveyard like Google of
products yeah so miss me with that part
then we got to talk about the Jade Raven
situation right
they didn't even commit to making their
own first party Studios
they didn't even they literally hired
her right then shut it down laid
everybody off and then my thing is how
serious are you because at the end of
the day if you're not even willing to
commit to make your own game Studio to
put on your product and then not only
that you insist on Linux oh my God
everything gotta be Linux and then oh by
the way developer you can't do no
windows emulation you can't do that if
you got it you gotta make it
specifically for us the guys that's not
in first place the guys that are not
dominating anything right so you you're
forcing damage to conform that then you
give up get out the first party game and
say no no your devs we're going to give
you the state of tech you go make
you go make on your own now so that just
showed me again it's questionable
decision making in terms of game
development how committed are you truly
are when you don't even commit on that
level and then look we got to be real
like again so I've said it like
look who's running it and I'm trying to
be very respectful you know Phil
Harrison is a legend in the space for
whatever for his his contributions I'm
not gonna say the bear doesn't he has
contributions but
we got to be real about the resume
the resume is what it is
right Playstation three
info games
Xbox One
Stadium
but I'm supposed to believe
that Bethesda is the all the sole reason
and it's like he said so like it's their
own hubris they I just think they felt
that they had the hottest Tech which
they did and the tech alone was going to
win them the war yeah you know shout out
to to real quick Jeff gershman Jeff
Griffin on his podcast I said like he's
like yo I talked to people coming out of
that Stadium presentation developers and
they were like yo they don't know what
they're doing they don't know what
they're talking about like they don't
there's nothing in there that indicates
they have any idea how to run this it's
all a bunch of like blow rating about
theoretical things that's all it is it's
just like a sheister thing like and he
was like and and there were very few
devs that actually believed in it here's
the thing like
the tech was fire
but I remember what was it E3 2018 all
of us went me you at it we go to
Microsoft theater
speak with the great Bill still well
xcloud is out right
infancy stages of x-cloud for the most
part
played it on a 720 screen on all turned
20 on a phone but this is playing Halo
seamless from that Convention Center
to Azure data center 400 miles away
whatever it was a Services yeah and we
like yo how is this even happening right
and then what we saw was the Trojan
Horse we literally did stay there and in
my opinion right then and there oh by
the way game passes in this game pass
yeah all these games to stream on the
phone the only question at the time that
Stadium had the advantage was that they
were in browser right they were in
browser first but then eventually which
call it came out ultimately I remember
when ultimate came out we're going to
offer that it's in beta but we're going
to offer Game Pass as part of the
ultimate subscription that was it it
wasn't even no Bethesda Acquisitions at
that time that was regular first party
Studios Game Pass they didn't have the
games period so again it's like miss me
with this excuse stuff and miss me with
this false flagging I don't know who's
telling you to do what or why you're
doing what but those ain't the reasons
so that's why it's a lot of this these
bad faith arguments that I'm seeing now
and I just want to know why because
who's doing this right because here's
where I with you kid and I normally I
you go off sometimes and I let you out
but I'm with UK because in Brazil
you didn't have nothing to say Google
nope in Brazil no that's fine Microsoft
could do whatever whatever all of a
sudden now now you going under they're
about to close the doors on you
all of a sudden you have something to
say interesting to me that's all I got
to say
Jimmy bones Jimmy bones yeah
tombstones Jimmy bones
October in Jimmy bones it's running wild
[Laughter]
[Music]
a little bit let me see
Jimmy running around going boo all right
we got it JD game remember for two years
five dollar Super Chat the real movies
from Microsoft to acquire both epic
games and cry Tech that allows them to
have control of development of games and
that's right and it's right up
Microsoft's alley yeah
if you have control of unreal and the
cry engine too
then we got Goku KO Superman two dollar
Super Chat came from Tick Tock Love The
Vibes you guys have yeah
[Laughter]
okay it would be five Microsoft acquires
epic Unity ain't crying he's added
another one for the engines and that
pretty much guarantees most games will
come to the Xbox
you have no more we have no more excuses
a monopoly
there we go remedy live and four pound
and 49 pen Super Chat uh breaking news
and Putin announces nuclear attacks
across the world citing Microsoft's
purchase of activism as the real reason
Jesus Christ that's kind of crazy yeah
then we got black Ronin three five seven
remember for what yeah five dollars for
champ one journalist said said this that
Phil has a track record of failing
upwards wow
[Music]
wow that kind of fits that works yeah
you've given this man chances to to
launch stuff um I heard he's in charge
of uh Playstation VR too oh no don't do
that I'm excited for that
there we go argue it's a team member
from with you 20 Super Chat trying to
block game pass PlayStation also blocks
stadia and Luna play play a PlayStation
money-headed games couldn't come to
stadium also stadia didn't make sense
save money buying a console in countries
that can afford it but pay full price
for All Games there you go as soon as
you told me you are sixty dollars for a
game that I would never even have I
wouldn't even have the digital rights to
right
and that's another thing we got to talk
about that up when they close the Shop
from Junior
so yeah one one quick thing before move
on yeah so uh the the there are
companies trying to work it out so that
they can transfer people's uh saves and
progress to other formats so I know io's
working on it I know Bungie's looking
into it as well so yeah
so shout out to them then we got uh yeah
baby ten dollar Super Chat we all had a
good laugh when King said this would be
the last Sony PlayStation but looking at
Sony's falling share prices he might be
right
now
40 down baby
let us Rock there we go yeah baby father
again five dollars Jimmy bones asked
Phil Harrison show us when Microsoft
touched you
whoa who touched me with my gun drop
buttons
not the gun drop buttons
to need uh five dollar Super Chat one
thing to keep in mind is also that
Google doesn't exactly have a great
relationship with the uh European Union
regularly oh they would rather not play
these games I'm like so maybe just keep
your mouth shut Google you know somebody
convince them to collude interesting
then we have Cedric H member for two
years twenty dollars
Mr Harrison is the Alien Parasite from
the thing imitating to get close to kill
them all wow
we got Corey Tidwell five dollars what's
that y'all better stop slandering Google
the stream is getting a little choppy
they got that YouTube
coming for us there we go Hardy to me
once again ten dollar Super Chat also
Google still makes a lot in gaming with
the Android store they're still in
gaming they would rather let ABK happen
so they can go after their own big
Acquisitions gaming or otherwise I
remember and we have we have the Saudi
uh fund out here trying to cop 13
billion dollars worth of Publishers too
so that's uh brother that's another
conversation yeah maybe five uh five
dollars Jim said Phil come out from
under the red car they caught us
yeah
that was crazy
I'm telling everyone if this deal fails
Sony is over why because the ABK
shareholders will never allow any games
to go on their platform no marketing
it's a possibility it surely is okay let
me see if anything else popped up
I'm gonna go back we got Hector the
Macho Man five dollar Super Chat be
careful out here these Sony fans are in
need of money and we'll be doing
anything for money stay safe out there
Lords and the road
wow what a Sony pot we good yeah we're
good we'll cut up no doubt let's get
into the next topic this is Kings I will
set it up for him
PlayStation Stars so I guess they're uh
uh loyalty program uh coming up a little
bit come coming under a little bit of
criticism and heat so uh Playstation is
giving top Stars members priority in
Customer Support shout out to video
games chronicle.com for the article they
said players are criticizing the move
which implies you other users will get a
poorer service so a lot of PlayStation
of Japan have been expressing the
displeasure in this service so the way
it works I guess it's a four-tier level
system where all players start at level
one and can work their way up to level
four by buying buying games and earning
trophies however some users are upset
that the level 4 tier which is unlocked
after buying four full price games from
the PlayStation store and earning 128
rare trophies rewards players with
improved customer service so that we
have some accounts from um
oh sorry in the level for tier perks
include commemorative collectible and a
promise that when contacting PlayStation
customer support you will be given
priority in the chat or order that's
where the issue seems to be with a lot
of the Japanese PlayStation Gamers so um
after they point this out
um this is it's been a lot of uh
response on Twitter so pretty much the
Japanese uh Playstation Gamers I'm
saying customer support must be equal
they're players who are only like a few
titles and play them and they're Gamers
who can't afford money or time and these
others said that uh that it should
instead be weighted towards newcomers
who are more likely to have issues you
say that the more you play with it the
more you prioritize customer support but
the more you play with it the less you
use custom support there's something
about that you should give priority to
beginners who are new the game and then
um they said if you're going to give up
give up a level based on time played or
something that's fine but ranking them
up by how much you charge is not likely
to get a very good response and the
final uh account I believe it says I
don't think it was a good idea to
prioritize customer support at a yasi
44. I bought a PS5 just for Final
Fantasy 16. is it okay for someone like
that to put put aside for later so this
is really going crazy oh man I just
looked up
you're feeling like a level one player
one
only us tier fours know what it means to
be about that life
this is here for the payers sir you know
y'all are not created equal
and if you want to get ahead in life you
got to pay your way to get to the front
of the line now I say level four people
tier four
their views in their time is very
important
they paid their way to get to the top
don't gripe about it just pay about it
oh man this is this this is how you
ensure quality this is you you get the
criminal cream so the let me let me give
you a for instance on how a phone call
will actually go we go get it okay all
right so yes scenario please explain
yes
hello welcome to Sony uh where customer
service is key uh may I ask you what's
your Gamertag and what is your tear oh
my gamer tag is a Xbox 360 level one
my tear I just started uh it's uh level
uh tear tear one okay uh can I play
short a brief hole
yes that's no problem waiting time will
be four days and 59 minutes okay and
here here here is if you are a premium
member this is exactly what Ah that's
Google okay now
hello welcome to Sony how may I help you
where the pair and the player is key
well uh well can I have your chair
please oh my chair is level four oh oh
wait a second hold on let me put you
right through yeah how may I help you
today
yes I'm having a problem right now I
can't get my crota my Kratos ax to
loading well we only got five of y'all
that's level four you must be Bob hey
Bob
oh my ax is here
I'm gonna throw I'm gonna throw a
variable in your your scenario okay yes
sir mid top you you refresh the screen
it goes from a four to three what
happens oh it seems like uh you lost
your tear there what can oh could you
can I place you on a brief hold
on
every 35 minutes
listen man
if you don't got the money to play in
this pool get out let's get out we have
no time for you if you're not paying
like you're weighing get out we want
only that premium people we want the
payers like listen for instance if
you're crying about the ten dollars for
a game we don't want you here
you gonna pay seventy dollars we want
you to walk in the store and buy proudly
because you're getting quality so listen
oh I can tell you a little bucket rules
your little level ones get up to tier
four where the ear is a little bit finer
the juice is a little bit more crisper
delicious ain't it in the hashtag
snitches why are you doing this in the
in the uh to the Japanese PlayStation
gamer and not officially announcing it
it wasn't supporting us anyway
[Laughter]
all right so don't don't cry don't cry
go out there and buy don't cry go bye
Wild Buck why isn't this service
launching officially in North America
was on a blog post you don't even
mention this tier system thing you only
mentioned it today no we have
competition over there
I'm gonna pull this crap over here we
only can go where we have no competition
we got competition over there Microsoft
is feverish and heaven then they they
keep they teaching and they have these
people out here learning about equality
you're not subscribed to that right
equality only things equal is this
dollar here and if you're not coming in
with the Bucks well you know what's up
wow so there's so Asia is a test test
run for yourself yeah that that is we we
knew that they weren't supporting so we
gave them exactly how they supported us
we support you how you we support how
you report it uneven
anyway I don't know attic is uh still
here we stepped away for a second but if
not I'm here yeah uh Playstation
um stars sir loyalty program thoughts
you know Japanese PlayStation fans are
not happy right now
you guys will have to excuse me I'm
eating mint ice cream okay
um no the mint can wait the mint can
wait Sony will get to smoke then I'll go
back to eat my mint actually
well in a way
I don't see an issue with this uh
because I do feel like there's a lot of
Premium you know customer service stuff
out there like Sam's Club I know that
Costco has their own version of it but I
do feel like what do you have to get the
trophies if we can get to level four or
is it just the games
I'm sorry say that again do you have to
get the trophies in order to get or is
it just the game um according to the
document it I believe it was a
combination so it says all right level
four is unlocked after buying four
full price games from the PlayStation
store and so that means 70 or 60 70 I
didn't say and earning 128 rare trophies
so you got to have the trophies and the
four games purchase and then you can be
level four so in order to qualify
theoretically uh from the verbiage
they're using you have to pay 280 plus
dollars
you can't go get a game on discount and
you can't come in here with these half
Behind trophies
what is it for a Sam's Club membership
with 50 bucks 50 bucks and you in there
man you get that card Sony like okay
we want 280 for him yeah and we want you
to play those games now look I'm not I'm
not the first person to say that don't
play them games but I'm saying man if
you pay them 280 dollars in a year I
personally feel like you deserve to be
on that list that's just me but but
Sony's like kill money ain't good enough
for us we want your time too
dedicated it's crazy man it's crazy
that's all I got to say I'm going back
to my man
they want your money and your sweat it's
awesome where we at PlayStation Stars
I just I look at some of the moves
they're making this this generation
and it's just like it has again it
doesn't feel like it's it's
a serious or as detrimental overall but
it's it's a lot of Xbox One energy with
like just stepping on like unforced
errors and stepping on a rake for no
reason it has been on this from the jump
he's like when are we gonna start
noticing like it's just it's just little
things little things that it's just like
yo do you not have a human being who
looked at this and said this ain't the
this is going to come off wrong even no
matter how minor the the group of people
that it affects or whatever it's just
gonna come off wrong because at the
moment any of this
is tied to monetary infusion is going to
look bad it's you be how are you gonna
that's gonna pay to win customer service
not to pay to win customer service like
come on man who who did not look at this
and say this doesn't look good this is
Twitter is going to go you need I I
firmly believe this in this day and age
every company needs a somebody who has
their ear to the ground when it comes to
how things can get manipulated and
changed and how and and how narratives
can be formed in social media and how
harmful that can be you need somebody
with their end of the ground with this
stuff looking at this stuff and saying
hey this ain't gonna come off right
right right and and because the sad part
about it just started to interrupt you
no no way is the numbers are so high
they don't care like and that's
different it's different when
something's hurting your bottom line
but for the most part these aren't
hurting their bottom lines and you know
what's funny is I was thinking about it
like they don't say a better customer
service they they just say like pretty
much like a faster customer service so
you're gonna be paying all this money
and playing all these games for just the
same shitty customer service that I'm
getting too so you just yeah it's not
you're not getting that service
you're gonna get the weight button wait
till you get your love
it's just a lot of like it's just it
just feels like nickel and Diamond all
the time and just it just does not feel
like and this is why we always have to
be careful of falling into the Trap
where we're all over here like
supporting and big upping what is
essentially marketing and it's marketing
it comes from all companies they all do
it but it was a whole lot of strong talk
in Xbox one generation literally so all
that's only had to do was say the
opposite of what Xbox is they were good
even if they had no intention of doing
that all they needed to say was the
opposite and they were good because the
games were there to support it here it's
just like it feels like they're behind
the eight ball and a lot of the
messaging and they have to Pivot and
they know it's going to look bad they
don't care it's gonna look bad or maybe
they're oblivious to the fact it's gonna
look bad and then they just deal with
the fall afterwards and like to addicts
point it is true it just seemed that the
reality of the Fallout isn't great
enough for them to even really care
about it you know it's the only thing
they do so sorry interrupt you again
it's like did the check clear yeah let's
keep going let's keep going money the
money guys in the building
yeah so I just don't I don't know what's
going to get them I what what is going
to happen this generation where they
stumble so badly and they look so bad
that people are gonna be like wait a
minute nah this is the sound but I don't
see push back no I don't see no pushback
I didn't see too many people at all I
don't see pushback so to me you that's
just enabler you you've enabled a
company to continue to do things because
yeah completely comfortable yeah because
a lot of people yeah especially when you
look at like the media like like Western
media whatever if it's not affecting us
directly there's no convo about this
right it's no convo about it and even if
it does it it gets it gets pigeonholed
in such a way it's like oh it's only
affecting the small amount of people
whatever it's not a big deal same way
you know again we don't I know we don't
get political here but we talk about the
Saudi Arabia stuff we talk about the
tencent and the China stuff and you know
it's a it's a lot of just not no
conversations around it but let's get to
the root of this let me be dancing my
thing is why when something is your
favorite you can't talk about that is
wrong on a base level yeah
you can still say yo I like this company
but this right here is not it no I I
think it was fine you don't find
interesting when people struggle they
they can't even say that and the first
thing is but what about what they're
doing but it's only this it didn't why
such a defense
to to put up all this what aboutism and
deflection when something is wrong like
if Microsoft with Microsoft did that
what is it the gold remember when they
did it oh they they switched up the gold
and they were like I was like bro that's
not it that's not it you know what I'm
saying when the situation we like that
ain't it
what I find interesting when it's a
certain group's favorite they can't even
enunciate the words they can't even the
first thing response is yo but they over
there did this and this don't really
it's not really that big a deal so
you're implying that they immediate
responses to snitch
they're repeating response
admission but not not to admit they're
wrong doing their immediate response
yeah so you're saying that that fan base
is
[Applause]
infected his fan base with a base level
of snitch all I'm saying is
they can't stop we gotta separate our
emotionality because we like something
that you can be critical it's okay it's
okay no one's gonna take any points away
from your love of Saudi Microsoft
Nintendo if they do something wrong no
one's gonna take away it's okay but it's
this defense it's my squad it's my team
I can't show weakness
it's like I've I've stated multiple
times so not for the price increases
right on games but
it's got it's to the point where you
know I've said it over and over again
they they got it the passion the goddess
like there's nothing we could do about
it like unless we ain't gonna play these
games like you're just gonna have to
deal with it but at the same time like
that's not gonna stop me from saying
this ain't right right but it's like but
Xbox did this but Xbox did that why
can't you admit a lot of people don't
they again
a lot of people go back to the argument
like you know they look at the Grandeur
of things and don't look at the fact
that the principles are all the same
they don't they don't care about it
thank you oh this is worse than this but
they're essentially the same thing so
you know I don't I never understood that
at the end of the day they're doing the
same thing just they don't understand
the mind of a snitch
the mind of a snitch is automatically
when Court snitch out right which
automatically with something don't go
their way snitch out if it is kick both
side I've seen
I don't identify with those no those
snitching dudes either when something
happens I say this is wrong right
you don't identify with the snitching
but it has Permian see those people that
you say do that actually migrated from
Sony over to Microsoft so it takes a
period of time for them to weed to
snitch out of their system right so we
got to give them the caveat it takes
time for the snitch to slide out of
their system I gotta get them and I love
I love this person shout out to
Christopher I love you like he has to do
it his period keep typing Microsoft
rewards as long as you have Mike
MasterCard okay that's fine that's funny
can you admit that this principle just
on base level just he wants a little
suck that's all I'm asking is in his
blood they're like why can't we just say
on a Basel you know what Cog this don't
look a little right but that may not
affect levels
I'm just saying why can't you type that
like why do I have to get a Spam text of
but Microsoft did this but Microsoft did
yeah
he's a high level snitch
I got a question though is this uh this
this leveling up right is this as of the
interpretation of this like is this as
of the because if that's the case I'm
like a level 20 snitch because I got I
got I got bad digital purchases on there
like no it so this is a remote
implementation of it yeah it's the
moment you jump into the ego grandfather
Yeah
I just want some therapy I just well
just to type that said to just say you
know what Yo God that's just that part
right there
you suffer from realness
is
being that you suffer from realness and
you watching you looking out the window
you say I can't believe all this
snitching is going on and nobody is
checking these news
be wrong over here too
is the crazy part is you can lose your
tier status every year yeah of course of
course of course they need you to stay
invested
so you're not copying that amount of
games a year if they would have came out
and they put this on like PlayStation
Plus that would have been different okay
you know PlayStation Plus get a little
priority okay but it's just like so so
yeah
Sony like you're gonna go out and you're
gonna spend 60 player on PlayStation
Plus okay I get the I get the the direct
line right the customer service line
that they're gonna tell me to screw
myself in the in the end anyway no
there's more then you're gonna go out
there and you're gonna spend and you're
gonna have to buy four games a year okay
I'll just get those indie games no
there's more okay full retail price
today I don't know about that so what if
it's only first party games and they
don't release four games
okay
okay so so all right all right so you
know regardless I guess that's
subjective but it's like even if you buy
20 games that's still 80 bucks then
they're like okay so you paid 50 60. now
you pay for uh 80 to uh up to 240 and
they're like okay now I get the direct
line no there's more now I want you to
play all it said like 180 games that's
more than those four games you got to
play more than the four games that you
bought and get more trophies 28 rare
trophies rare
you can't come in there with the bogot's
trophies you gotta come in there with 28
platinums so if you ain't no yeah it's
it's just like
you put that into place you talk about
them then charging the PlayStation 5 tax
you talk about them you know charging
people to to use the attic talk about
now I know why I couldn't get through
I am level tier one I know why now I
could y'all wonder I can't get my
Gamertag
come on Sony
games I'm not Godfather dude oh I need
to get four games a year and I gotta
play my plan wow so you can really do
this to me yeah I supported you
I think the issue is is it's okay to to
be selfish in a lot of scenarios these
companies got to be to make money but
it's just like when are we going to get
to the point where it's like when's
enough no that's a fact and that's
that's literally what I was trying to
say all right and the biggest thing I
have an issue is the lack of coverage I
feel like people will will make one
article IGN and all them they'll do one
article and then after about a week of
coverage on it then it's over well I
don't know an argument what's happening
is
because this is the vibe I'm getting and
correct me if I'm wrong I gotta ask a
question I got you is that a lot of
these practices what we're seeing right
now recently are being debuted in other
regions so the United States PlayStation
fan is unaffected technically at this
moment right so the thing that I am
concerned about is that
your PlayStation Brothers in Japan are
like yo this is awful this is terrible
you know what I'm saying other people
and other people saying hey I gotta
spend way more money now to get a PS5 my
thing is again I understand it's not
affecting you directly but what's that
expression when you keep allowing other
things to happen you know what I'm
saying and then don't get surprised when
things do happen to you without you not
saying anything because your love of the
company is so strong you can't say hey
on a principal level you know what
that's wrong what's happening to my
brothers over there that's really that's
really messed up and I think that's all
I'm saying I think the bigger issue too
is just like it's not just one two three
things we literally just got off for
them saying that they're going to
increase the price of a PlayStation five
people having a hard time getting a hold
of in the first place and multiple
countries but America which is weird uh
then they did the the place the the
PlayStation Plus that they then they did
the uh you know the the tax increase on
everything like it's just like I just
don't understand why they don't get
smoke for this it's like I said they get
a little bit of coverage but then people
just act like it doesn't happen anymore
like it's like they've done nothing over
and over again but raise prices on
consumers and I feel like I feel like
they get away with it like they they
don't get a lot of public publicity I
can't say that it's absolutely we're not
going to sugarcoat it is there's a
there's a cachet for the history and the
quality of the games prior and that has
allowed them to circumvent that that's
just what it is right my thing is all I
say is can we at least just acknowledge
that's all the first step is
acknowledging that something or the
principle level does it look right
that's always it after that you can make
a decision to stay or whatever whatever
that's all I said I just want
accountability I'm just tired of
this and what about and this ain't that
bad and it's like yo it's just a
principle that's always saying because
at the same time I'm telling y'all right
now y'all know my motto I'm not telling
you what you want I'm telling what you
need to hear Xbox everybody get to smoke
when there's some foolishness that's
going on we gonna talk about it that's
just a fact go ahead kick I'm sorry is
Kentucky based out of Japan
I just I'm just asking a question
mm-hmm
um
okay so the fact that they name sound
like they based out oh my God oh my God
I'm just saying I'm just saying right
did they report on this
who did Kotaku report on this specific
on this oh on the Stars I got this from
uh video games but they didn't report on
this but Chicago report on Microsoft
you know what it is
it's out of Sony preference it's it's
fear of being blacklisted by saying
anything negative about PlayStation
no I just I just want a intellectual
honesty there's a lot there's a lot of
them you're suffering from realness you
know you're suffering from realness and
you're looking at the hypocrisy and the
fake out there and it's driving you
insane I know one thing that I can tell
you
all you got to do is support the stop
snitching movement and see it it's
ingrained in them they point the finger
and they don't point the finger back at
themselves because they don't want to
acknowledge stuff is wrong
intellectual dishonesty and bad faith
arguments and that's all I want to point
out and people that know they're doing
it doing it and you know what it's
probably the game and maybe it's just me
I shouldn't even be acknowledging
because part of the Troll game and I
should just finish yes with certain
things but I just had like a snitching
Manchester anyway that's it for me we
are good moving on last one uh any other
Super Chat sir yeah hold on you know
what's funny I think we would read in
super chats and we got sidetracked by
the conversation yeah it just kept going
yeah
uh Jimmy bones you read that uh Alien
Parasite hold on a second let me scroll
down
and
what else we got
uh we got free R Kelly five dollars and
just say you can't afford Sony I'll lend
you the money
yo yo girls girls you can't afford
something
which I said you'll later Linda to buy
somebody come out of here
at this moment they pricing you out you
should have just took that money and
bought some Ramen for next week man yo
the moment that hit USA kills
you're finished
then we got uh damn it was it just
looked at it hold on a second damn it
back to kills
back together
Super Chat top quality
said it was wow you got some real some
real Peter Brady yeah
we gotta argue City member for that one
year ten dollars with that top quality
in quotation marks customer service only
PlayStations can make you pay extra even
to get support damn what's next
subscription to use your PS5 will give
you two teraflops two teraflops base pay
15 a month to unlock the 10.28 teraflops
yeah and we got man thing go make
seconds for two years ten dollars to be
chat gym out here snitching like meat
Canyon episode what's the episode uh
Phil made me turn his Gumball knob
slowly important
two of his golf balls whoa he whispered
in my ear that I'm his favorite and not
to tell anyone I don't know what this is
I don't know where that's going but we
gonna move on
I feel like you you might need to call
the cops
[Laughter]
[Music]
running a business is all business see
this is the problem though in gaming
right when you say it's all business
gaming is different because it's a hobby
where you have you have smart people
that are engaged in the business of it
as well as the games of it it's not like
any other hobby everybody's engaged in
some way shape or form so you have to be
friendly to your consumer in a way that
look if I love TVs I'm not expecting
Sony to be out here with a with you know
a TV spokesperson to be telling me but
you know it's different it's just
totally different
then we got sir R Kelly again five
dollars of attack it's simple gang
addict if you broke just say that and
they got the broke section it's called
Xbox
man you know what's funny
yeah you know what's funny uh uh uh R
Kelly is that you uh you ain't even you
ain't even Super Chat enough to get a a
subscription for a month of Xbox Live
ultimate yeah you got to sit down
he gonna miss out on his ramen noodles
his crackers next month I don't feel bad
at all he just gotta do more push-ups in
the yard
we got THX 11 30 eight two dollars Super
Chat Stars which stands for Sony
transaction assessment Revenue Service
wow wow
Sony transaction assessment Revenue
Service my man you have definitely made
my day that man made a whole acronym
then we have RnB AKA The Underground
gamer with the five dollar Super Chat
Sony pisses on Facebook and they start
singing in the rain Microsoft cough said
gets accused of sexual harassment wow
wow
you're right my goodness
moving on
King and I have been successful you
peons have been removed
from the early days of e3 so we can get
our job done damn it uh-huh
[Laughter]
yo those two right mm-hmm
they'd be acting like we don't we don't
we don't eat off of this yeah but you
didn't care you thought it was gonna
happen you thought what's gonna happen
it don't matter what I thought it don't
matter what I thought it means the
outcome you know
these two will be the first in line be
like oh excuse me
for the good of mankind you should be
thanking me for a great for disagreeing
with you to make sure that happens
this sounds like the Phil luminous
argument
has jumped over on our yacht that is
cruising up the street shout out to the
esa did you know I had like a little
raft that was just that had like a line
on the yacht I was never on the other
boat I just made you guys think I was on
the other you were just hanging off the
side yeah it's in the Jitsu right so
yeah shout out to the esa and read pops
so repop came out and sort of finally
gave back the dates for E3 and they gave
sort of the breakdown of what they want
to do with E3 2023 coming back to the
Los Angeles Convention Center and so
what repop is doing is super interesting
first of all let's talk about the
scheduling right we laughed about it but
so it's going to run from Tuesday to
Friday
with the uh with Sunday prior to that
Tuesday opening being I guess set aside
for for uh Whatchamacallit for press
conferences and things of that nature so
kind of the way it's always been except
for the fact that the Saturday
doesn't seem to include any press
conferences it seems to be Sunday with
partner organizations for sort of press
conferences and then the Monday also
seems to be set aside for that though
there's no official sort of e3 sort of
schedule for that day so the Tuesday to
Friday is going to be set up where the
Tuesday and Wednesday are only for press
to you know go in and get the job done
go get get their interviews see these
previews of these games and be able to
sort of move from place to place kind of
unhindered
by the by the craziness and then so
Thursday is going to be an overlap day
where you're going to have press and
you're going to have uh the the the
masses come in and then Friday is going
to be only for fans which is great
um it's Friday and Saturday for fans
yeah
[Laughter]
so uh yeah I mean I think this is great
I think we talked about this before I
just think uh in order to make this work
where it works for the press as well as
for the fans you have to have you have
to separate a little bit so everybody
can Preston get the job done and the
fans can enjoy something that is super
just fan Centric and at the same time
the Press isn't getting in that way so I
think this is great on read pops part
that's going to work so well solved I'm
so glad I thought of it
don't want to give them knees them
that's fine that's fine like a Sony dude
so you gotta let them have this the
other thing that's interesting
yes the other thing that's interesting
about this and I want you guys to
comment on this is the fact that read
pop seemed like they step back to see
what the esa was really doing wrong and
say okay how do we change people's
perception of this show and one thing
that they're really doing is focusing on
making E3 once again the place where the
industry unites and everyone is welcome
even if you're not in the convention
center paying whatever the esa needs you
to pay to to have a booth there or do
whatever if you are there during the
time of e3 and you want to partner
whatever you're doing whether it's
Microsoft on the outside whether it's EA
on the outside the door is open for that
to happen in a way that unifies the
entire week under a banner with which is
what they want to do they say hey
regardless of where you're where you
where you're presenting what you're
doing we want all of the industry to be
together as one I think this is where
this show has always been the strongest
and we need to bring back a semblance of
that even if you know again Keith is
going to be doing his own thing other uh
Publishers are going to be doing their
own separate thing they want to bring it
all together under an umbrella that
feels like it's a cohesive one week of
just again gaming Christmas as a lot of
people call it the Super Bowl of gaming
um so I think I in theory I love this I
hope that they're able to accomplish it
I don't know because of the business
behind it right keeley's doing his own
thing a lot of other companies doing
their own thing
what are the conversations that need to
happen for this to to be a reality but
again we're going to be there we're
going to enjoy this for what it is I'm
glad that it's coming back uh I love
seeing this I love seeing this a lot of
people talk them out during the pandemic
listen man we don't need this we're
doing this and in in a way it's it's
you're right you're right about that you
know there's money to be spent there's a
whole lot of stuff but there as someone
who's been there not as many times as
the rest of these guys but just to be
there to see the Pomp and Circumstance
to walk into a room that is all about
the stuff that you love it's a special
feeling so I'm glad that it's coming
back we'll see if Reed pop re-pop does
very well with all the other stuff they
do it feels like they really step back
and assess what was wrong with E3 and
are trying to address that so we'll see
if it works but for me it's a go I'm
happy to see this I wonder what you guys
think about it
but we think you eat three back two days
media what you call it consumers get
their own day is this
it's definitely the right call
especially when I you know I thought of
it
no a realistic thing uh you know it I
remember correctly like me me and Carl
you know we wanted this to happen it's
just I didn't know they would make this
decision because I felt like it as a
company it makes more sense to go after
the back uh I am glad that they found a
good middle balance it's just like Saul
said well like it's one thing to see oh
it looks good on paper I just got to see
how well it works because even if it's a
complete hit for the industry for people
who cover the industry like us if they
don't make much money then was it even
is it even easier thing right no good
point good point Lord King victorious in
his bougie run with solve happy about
the two days here sir for media I
remember they tried to get us to bend
the knee on this yeah thank God I didn't
do it
shout out to my man Suave
if you watching baby I'm getting your
taxes your texts look good
I got two good news today to talk about
right now
my Jets winning cause we don't get them
often good job with this dude second
second
all you dudes we don't need E3
E3 is gone it's the way to Dinosaur we
don't need it I laugh at you I laugh at
you because somebody said no we do and
your vote didn't matter
and you know what vote mattered because
only me and this dude sat there and said
exactly what they should do and this is
exactly what they did
your vote don't matter your voice was
not heard but our voices Was Heard and
you can say whatever
you can say whatever they ain't
listening to you King obviously that's a
lie
obviously that is a lot they listen to
you because if they listen to you and
maybe maybe you felt a little
disgruntled maybe you know you you like
sitting in your house and not getting up
and and the way the things is going that
you had to go out there and make content
instead of waiting for content to come
to you waiting for IGN or somebody else
that is out there with their boots on
the ground to bring the information well
here at lordsagaming.net
and I ain't lost podcast we embrace
the people we Embrace going out talking
to developers we embrace the struggle of
going out there making news making it
factual giving you something to know
the the family and the fan base that we
have
Hold Us in high regard because we go out
there to do that to bring it back to
them
and and we'll be frauds if we've rooted
and voted for E3 to go away
and and for it to go to this digital
format where we're not there where we're
shut out
the doors is back open baby
I feel that Friday and Saturdays for
them dudes that want to play around and
and and play video games
in the days that's for media to get down
and dirty and to find out exactly what
makes these games tick how did they do
it what engines did they use did they
run into any obstacles the questions
that you ask us
that we go back and ask them
and we able to post that stuff and bring
that stuff to you so you can get it
first
so you don't gotta wait and you can a la
carte how you want to view your stuff
you don't have to sit through boring
stuff like uh somebody giving you an
advertisement to sell some sneakers or a
car or something that you don't care
about
um
to get back to real gaming where the
politics is not there you don't have to
we ain't gonna bring no friends out
talking about uh we pushing their game
you know what we talking about if you
don't want that dude all up in your
video
all of it all up in your your podcast
listen to us I'm just so happy that it's
back and we're gonna be there
with oh my God Division I was talking to
somebody last night shout out to you
because I know you're watching
um
and he's a huge supporter and I told him
how we roll
we're gonna be in Beverly Hills oh damn
we're gonna be close to the convention
center okay
we're going to have podcasters there
our family the camaraderie is like no
other oh that's a fact that that that
boom I know boom is Head Over Heels
crazy to to to see the smile
on people's faces to break bread with
people in the industry to have real
meaningful conversations and sometimes
never reach it to to to to to talk about
that that part is invaluable to build
bonds to get a chance to see Toby and
everybody in person I mean
I I never wish for it to go away so when
it happened and it happened in the
manner that we asked for
this this is only a blessing guys and I
swear we're going to work the hardest
for you guys we're going to bring you
the best coverage for you guys we're
going to do the best that we possibly
can because they delivered at how we act
so I'm standing here shoulder to
shoulder with my brother yeah we fought
the good fight
and we're Victorious
we're Victorious thank you
and I tell you this I'll tell you this
if ever
Sovereign is in line with anything that
I say me and him can move mountains
that's true that is kind of true
anytime y'all look over here
I'm just saying y'all never know because
we always so diametrically right a lot
of stuff exactly well we agree yeah
that's true
that is true that is true I'll give
y'all that I'll give it yeah
this I was like no because you know why
because when they started switching and
letting and letting in the fans it was
like it was completely out to the
detriment of what the completely to the
detriment of what the Press was doing
right you know right and secondly
secondly my first ethernet
that's what this is let's get to it my
first day three I went I was like yo I'm
gonna be able to go in and we'll go with
the team and do this and this is us
still sort of it's starting up right a
couple of times King have been there a
couple of times I've been there a couple
of times so I know some of y'all had um
is the thing the very first E3 you went
to or or maybe it just no no you we were
podcasting that's for sure so it was but
it we we weren't you know I don't think
the the website was still a thing I
I know some of you guys had uh uh what
you would call a Fan Fest you had a
little bit of an inside to go see these
things or whatever correct and when I
went I was shut out of everything I know
you're right like everything everything
and but it was one of those things where
it was the Press at the same time had
very little time to do the job as well
and they were tussling with the fans and
it's like well it just didn't make a lot
of sense so as you know as as we've
progressed and grown and been having
more and more access and being able to
interview these devs and you know and
people recognizing us and knowing us
when we go
um
you want to be able to give that that
type of coverage right you want to go
and do do your best work and I every
time that I I was able to go to like to
PAX East and you see like the difference
in how it's run right and again shout
out to repot you know those those have
been very different types of events yes
but you go and the devs are on the floor
right and it could be the devs could be
on the floor for a larger game as if
specifically you're going to see a lot
more small games but you're going to see
large games as well and they're just
there to talk to you and the mixture
there is very fan Centric right but
again you can still go and be like hey I
have this interview I have this thing
they put you off into the room to the
side you sit there and you talk with
them and generally you're able to get
your job done in a way that doesn't feel
like you're imposing upon the fan and
vice versa the same as well so for me
it's like nah man
the coverage has to be there and it has
to be there so people could just do the
job they're right you know people in
this industry for a long ass time
and for you to now have to be like wait
on the line to to be able to speak to a
Dev when you just want to get in and see
the game get your coverage up another
thing about that is the way the world
has changed everything is about post
stuff up first like there's a lot of
that involved right so if you're having
to wait and you have a you have a time
of one o'clock for a meeting and they
can't get you into 215 whether you're
waiting because other people online and
there's really no cue it so this is a
lot so to me this is the right way to do
it where it's it gives it they have to
figure out how to make E3 relevant again
for every everybody and that's that's a
hard thing to do so having to balance it
between the press and the fans for it to
be it just had to happen so I'm glad
that again we don't know if it's going
to be successful but at least they're
attempting to do it in a way that the
esa by themselves let's not do it I got
a shout out court with it I agree with
soft I hate it with E3 friends try to
squeegee by right
wow
so that's it I mean that's it man I
think
hopefully it turns out the way they want
and if it does turn out that way I
really do think that press and fans
alike are going to be grateful that they
aren't stepping on each other's toes in
that way yeah I think so no for the
record I was never
opposed to it for the record I just said
I don't know if they doing it that's
what my thing was because I was just
like wow two days yeah of course am I
gonna say no like I said there of course
I would be right in there with y'all
doing the thing but yeah to your credit
you know they definitely valued what
y'all had to say from a media
perspective and I think now that I think
about it it does make sense because
let's be real a lot of the reasons why
E3 one of the major reasons why E3
really started to drop off besides the
pandemic was we can't ignore that major
data leak that happened right and that
pissed off a lot of journalists a lot of
media a lot of content creators was
information was you know it was it was
compromised so they have to earn a lot
of trust so I think this is the right
way to give the media what they want if
you truly intend to make a comeback
second like so I've said huge fan of
repop you know they've been I love the
E3 structure the event it's fan you know
consumer friendly for the most part you
know the separation I was surprised I
didn't think they would do a complete
separation the consumers get their own
day media get the two that's cool I want
to see what they do with the Ken to your
whole thing the only questions I have I
think Nintendo and Xbox should be back
in a big way I think Nintendo after
being at Pax West Nintendo was outside
like old I was like oh they're ready to
be back in the convention in a full form
that's for two and three was popping he
had the big set up The Bigs like this
too remember they had the stuff they do
right and then but Pax West was like the
show out so to me they're gearing up and
I guess yeah I guess the biggest
question is can Sony separate the esa
now the question is going to be soldi
now historically they have not gone back
the other thing is we keep forgetting
about the elephant in the room
the way they sound if they do it
correctly satellite E3 can be back in a
big way the question is was Jeff
keighley gonna do because Jeff in summer
game Fest was supposed to be the answer
and his thing so I am one and here's the
thing to me it's like where does Sony
land that Sony say okay we're still not
messing with the esa do they mess with
Jeff or do they just say nope we're
still not doing any convention stuff
because I would like to Sony to be in
some capacity I mean if they're not they
don't get me wrong they're gonna have a
paid tail
you have to get into day joint you have
to pay to get into this
I think Xbox will be back my only
question with Xbox is we know they're
gonna probably do the Microsoft Center
again right most likely going to do that
Sunday uh press conference you know what
I'm saying Microsoft has a lot like it
could be lit because think about this
they could do the Microsoft theater for
the for the separate joint off of site
right and the esa said we're gonna
promote all the off-site events as if
it's one big family so that's a big deal
they're acknowledging all other events
you across the town but we still see we
still see you know what I'm saying we're
not separate you got that does Microsoft
come back into the Halls again that I
want to know remember that's the old
school there too they had this stuff
there
remember they had mixer stuff they had
mixer stuff when mixer was a thing about
a Microsoft Centric stuff the Xbox stuff
was just in the morning
I don't know if they come back to the
floor but I want to see that and then um
here's the thing though
let's be real king
David acting like it's the Microsoft
Bethesda conference
we know who had the best conferences
every time it was time to test out
we don't pay we're not Sony we don't pay
for do you to be out there parading
yourself like you don't you uh
knocking cave stuff
yeah and then next is gonna be the
Activision Microsoft because if the
Activision Blizzard thing finalized
which should finalize if before E3 you
know when you pull up on that main
street was it Figaro or whatever and
it's always Call of Duty in Activision
that's the whole advertisement you're
just gonna be in green
Activision Microsoft show listen dude
they don't gave them that year for the
dudes to get comfortable with the
Bethesda Microsoft acquisition they
don't gave you that yeah to get
comfortable with this marriage you in
the pocket now so no no it's gonna be
okay because you can have
the Bethesda show Tuesday uh the
Microsoft show that's that's gonna stop
all right but here's the thing all right
I see what you say it makes sense but we
gotta Also let's be real quick with
these actors think about how many games
they got to shoot yeah I'm not I'm not
saying that they're not gonna show all
these games let's say the Activision
joint go down right you got all of those
Studios then you got all of xenomax then
you still got Microsoft first party they
talking Starfield talking about a hell
of a week but my thing is how can you
legitly fit all of that in just the one
show oh no no no it's gonna they're
gonna separate it into multiple shows
throughout the week okay but you're
gonna have your bangers that's coming up
they did the smartest thing they did was
give you this six month 12 month uh
situation right they're going to show
you for that first show was going to be
for the first six to 12 months worth of
stuff and then everything else after
that is going to be future projects and
stuff to to to keep you into the
ecosystem you know for uh later on
because a lot of people's complaining
that they didn't show anything past
those dates right yeah you could have uh
separate shows to show later on stuff
but for that main show that main show is
going to concentrate on that first six
to 12 months of stuff that you're gonna
get within that fiscal year uh that will
that that the gaming Year from June to
June
I actually have a different opinion
I I think that there's they're going to
keep the 12 months up
and all the companies going to be
together it's not going to be like a
Microsoft uh you know Activision thing a
Microsoft Bethesda thing it's going to
be we're naming this uh the Xbox
showcase and if you have games it's
ready you'll be in that showcase but you
don't you'll be in next year's show so
no separate now but but I think
separating it good no finish up I said
but I do think that they're going to you
know the the extended one they're gonna
really focus on that too they're going
to give all the DLC stuff to that
they're going to give all the you know
let's say a new character for OverWatch
comes out new uh new season for uh for
war zone like you're gonna see a lot
more of that stuff in there
yeah and that's the thing like I think
kind of separating it I mean again I
understand everything in the one batter
Banner yeah Kane oh my God yeah oh
actually I'm gonna put that I'm gonna
put that in the chat on the the cane
survey I need people to get that but um
for me I don't know if they separate it
out then you then you you capture the
narrative for the whole damn week if you
do that right you separate them out you
have like you know the Xbox first party
stuff then you again hey it seems like
the Bethesda stuff they always they want
them to keep that that building right
the identity even though everybody knows
it's within Microsoft and I think the
Activision Builders think would be the
same imagine having three separate shows
I get it because you really do capture
the thing as though is let's say that
there's like activations working on a
big game let's say once uh when
um what's when the next Elder Scrolls
comes out like I just don't see
Microsoft being like you show that hot
stuff on your stage and we'll show
what's on our stage right but
immediately but immediately showing it
if you go and you show the first
gameplay of Elder Scrolls right on on
the on the on in on the Bethesda stage
right let's say that at the very end you
know
coming day one Xbox game pass right just
to tell the people that don't understand
that right boom come again
Game Pass exclusive day one okay right
you now you just keep reinforcing that
message multiple times throughout the
week so the person the gaming fan that's
just tuning in maybe for the first time
it's like oh my God this dude what is
this E3 thing all these different
announcements they just keep getting
bashed over the head with Xbox game pass
Microsoft Bethesda Activision Blizzard
all of these things are in line with
each other and you you you kind of divvy
that up throughout the week you own the
week especially if you have big
announcements right I get I get both
ways to do it right I get both ways to
do it but E3 is one of those things when
you talk about winning E3 right when
you're winning E3 is is a thing where
it's like
if all that can happen under Xbox's roof
on in an hour and a half show hour 45
minutes whatever the case may be if Sony
comes up with one thing that is like the
most exciting thing ever another Marvel
game whatever the case may be whatever
was set at the Microsoft conference if
that was goes first because we already
know about who goes first in the
narrative around that sort of stuff that
could potentially be derailed right
separating the stuff gives you an
opportunity to come back with a salvo
after a big solvable from risonia or
Nintendo let me ask you this then if
they let them separate it you needed to
tell me that Xbox
spent 70 plus billion dollars in the IP
that they're never going to
but it's all going to be Xbox Centric
it's Xbox Centric but let's be right
here if you go out there and you say an
Activision thing that a lot of people
probably even know they bought Bethesda
at this point like casual audience and
stuff the people that you go walk up
there and you start seeing the game
slowly go exclusive that you'll get a
little bit more of that but if you have
some random person on Twitter seeing I
just don't see them be like yo the next
Call of Duty is not being shown on Xbox
and stage
of buying that if you can't promote it
but it is all Xbox's stage you can still
call it the Xbox Activision Blizzard
thing and it'd be a separate thing than
than the Xbox one right about this song
because someone in the champ made a
point what about like that they need to
show unity and to combine it like on one
stage because you got to convince you
got to show that the the common person
that this is now under the Xbox brand
why don't you just flip it and turn the
narrative around make a deposit and be
like we have so much stuff that we can't
have you sitting here for three hours oh
okay so you could be like we'll announce
it here and and if you want more details
you go to that right it's all about
changing the narrative right you're
looking at it as a straight up negative
and separating the message whereas you
can expand the message okay it's not
about being negative or anything it's
just like to me when I see something
like that I personally feel like if that
was the case they would have they would
have separated Bethesda and Xbox like
they put them together right so it's
just like my mind sits like why would
they change that mentality when they
bought something as big as [ __ ]
they put them together because they
didn't have a lot to show the show what
they had to show was was two PlayStation
games but to addicts quite though you're
going to get to a point though like
what's going like you go get to a point
where it's gonna be what did they buy
Sega computer
I would own the week I'm like all right
you go this day we go this day I don't
care it's Microsoft and then you you got
to look at it from a standpoint that
they do get an allocated budget for
these kind of events having six
different shows is huge is hugely
expensive I get it I get it but without
doing that something's going to fall to
the Wayside right yes it's called all
the good stuff's gonna go to one show
all besides that's going to go to
another show and then decide right the
sideshow the the addition whatever they
call it the Edition
that's never really fun like
but when you start adding OverWatch
characters to that you start adding
Diablo DLCs to that you start adding uh
the stuff they currently have sea
thieves like you start adding the next
State of Decay stuff on that like these
games of service if Halo wouldn't have
been jacked up you could have added that
to it flash
um they did purchase kin
and they have both full division yes
showcase that would be absolutely dope
and I think y'all should go with that
yeah
somebody's gonna get behind now 100 and
you have me come out there
we go
just be a little royalty thing I I got
the whole
Concepts
it's a good it's a good question it's a
good problem to have right yes that's
the best problem bottom line it is a
good problem now you know who don't have
that problem
moving on from you that's all I had to
say with that and then pretty much like
I said Nintendo and you know fan fast
hopefully comes back
to this [ __ ] that'll be dope and I just
want to see what Jeff kinkley do but
that's all I got is out of here yeah you
do okay hold on a moment
don't have that many additional ones
yeah chat this thing keeps rolling me
yeah but I'm like yo split up people
like nah keep it together
I think this logically it makes more
sense to have one show that shows all
the good stuff instead of having three
to four shows or some sprinkle good here
some sprinkle good there like We
complain all the time that they fluff
out these stuff because they don't have
necessarily enough to show and then Saul
wants me to to to okay the fact that
they finally got enough substance to
show one show with with great
announcements after great announcement
so I was like yeah split that now so now
it becomes I don't want to have just
draw stories
I want them they're gonna have enough
stuff to do the hour do the hour on this
show now on the next show dude I wanna
next
throughout the whole week besides
Activision I just don't see Bethesda
being that we'll have something to show
every year either like these Studios
they might be besides Call of Duty
what what else is Activision going so
yearly to have a whole show this is the
thing that this is the problem that
needs to be rectified right yeah yeah I
mean they have to they have to figure
out like Activision Builders can't just
continue to be the Call of Duty machine
they have to come it has to be more than
that right so that's a problem that they
need to fix too I'm scared of and
another problem is like you'll upset
people because you'll take announcements
from blizzardcon from overwatch's thing
like it's just like I that's the reason
you don't see Activision and stuff like
in huge thing because they announce
their stuff all year long and all these
other different events I don't
necessarily think that should change
though because
we like them to fish but the thing is
like I don't I I don't feel like
just because I want more stuff at a show
that I should like try with them
somebody else yeah take away from
someone else's Community I don't play
league of not League of Legends wow like
that but for me to say yo I know you
guys have been used to this but we need
announcements so we snatch them
I wasn't doing right by you so we had to
purchase yourself
you don't know what's good for you but
we do God bless
Beer Baron in the Chesters I say put all
35 Studios on cardboard
every every three four months oh real
quick there's two rumors why are you
going to switch let me read oh yes
they like yo you gotta talk about it all
right so the first one is it looks like
there is a report about Horizon zero
Dawn remake and a remaster of it in
works for PS5 Horizon multiplayer game
in development so uh yeah shot looks
like they would have potentially
remaster It One Source didn't said if
you thought Last of Us was divided
players up and whether or not it needs
to remake prepare yourselves it's been
revealed to us that PlayStation is now
remaking or remastering details are
still unclear Horizon zero Dawn a game
that is only five years old and has had
its sequel released earlier this year
our source that this is mpfirst.com so
over there our source didn't elaborate
whether or not this was a built from the
ground up style of remake however we
were told that the Remake features an
improved lighting system ambient
inclusion inside overhaul textures and
better animations with new character
battles so yeah that would be
interesting you know in a short cycle
that's pathetic if that's true yeah I
mean and the thing about it is right
that we don't know the thing is okay
here sure you want to remaster and do
all those hot little you know technical
things behind the scenes it's gonna cost
you seventy dollars to get it outside of
that we were told there is a big focus
on bringing accessibility options to
this okay sequel to introduce different
graphic modes vrr support for PS5 take
advantage
each one of those things put a dollar
down
it is and it adds up to 69.99
so yeah that the streets is talking you
know that they're looking to remaster
this and then it says two sources
verified that the project is indeed real
with the third giving some brief take
details that it may feature a form of
Co-op customization is said to be around
the attic's lab around the different
tribes established in the Horizon
franchise however we have not been able
to verify the know the details whether
that online
um and it said yeah so this this is a
thing going around right now about
another remaster is this gonna be the
Playbook y'all just rebasting the games
they buying it they doing it this is
their life now they can't come up with
anything new so they gonna go back to
the old stuff and pretty it up that's
what they do God bless enjoy bye let's
say less it really feels like it really
feels like
there's a big shift coming we want to
see a lot of those service-based games
whatever they're not really they're not
even remotely ready and they're just
that they're they're they're showing up
you know they need stuff to come out
this is the attic we at the end we're
starving we're hungry we're sleepy and
we need to put on a life raft to hold us
into place so I just wanna I just want
to say one thing
who gave permission to to go off subject
on super chats to get out this is what
I'm saying like we we were at the door
we we
it's like
it's like equivalent to being about to
be served that five course
meals
did they put the plate on the table they
said wait a second wait a second wait a
second the shrimps
give me my shrimps not gonna try to be
good journalists
I gotta get to provocative
how do you like that apparently there is
a there apparently there's a fifth
secret tier of PlayStation Stars yeah
yeah
you got to buy five PlayStation fives is
this the diamonds here
I go to the video It's gotta go uh
hidden in invite only
[ __ ]
this is the only way the SSD works
Leonardo DiCaprio
[Laughter]
give me your hand
it's too much news for you
oh my God I'm done continue
Jabba bars put the crust in the chat for
Jabba bars newest member to the road
then we got the rubber knob
I think Microsoft will do their own and
Bethesda and ABK will do one together I
don't know because that that means
because they're gonna be beef today
because like wait a minute why don't we
get on that
that's it all right all right see you
guys later
yeah we do that that thing
with the recent rumors regarding a
potential Halo infinite engine change to
Unreal Engine what do you think should
be the best course of action for 343
moving forward the choices are a a b c d
addicts right let's go hey stay with
slip space engine changing engines at
this stage of Halo infinite development
makes no sense and makes the content
drought even longer B launch Battle
Royale to buy more time for the eventual
transition to Unreal Engine C plug pull
the plug on Halo infinite completely to
work on a new Halo game or D I don't
care what engine they use until they
explain what happened in Spartan lock
shout out
shout out to all those in the chat
everybody rocking the pole it will go up
on Twitter against salute everybody in
the realm holding this down again go
make sure I hit up valari.com we got it
pinned up in the chat we're gonna have
that exclusive deusive ILP you know what
I'm saying get your gaming pillow on for
you for your neck if you want to use it
oh I gotta fall asleep right here
and you put that controller bad boy on
it you're doing your long gaming session
you're rocking and rolling not like that
though we can't do it like this
again it's a premium product to make
sure y'all support though it is a very
very effective I'm calling it for all my
Ballers non-ballers all the Realms to
come out and purchase it's gonna be
unlimited quantities but I'm telling you
right now I'm fitting to go to sleep
in the pool I'm done when we say it once
they're gone they will never be this
pillow again yes this will be a limited
edition shout out to the Friends of
valari make sure y'all hit them up on
Twitter it's pinned up in the chat right
there go go hit them up and say we saw
it we we want to wait for the ILP
pre-order page they're gonna hit you
with the link they're gonna do it it's
gonna be lit but we're gonna announce it
officially though no doubt so anyway
we're going to five people find what you
got going on Sir stop sleeping okay you
can find me on Twitter at Lord addict
IOP
um appreciate for coming through we we
will be having uh some announcements
here soon
um teasers
[Laughter]
at like 700 and uh like 80 people at
once so you guys come up here every week
we appreciate it
I've got to I know you guys want us to
play uh grounded so I guess we'll start
focusing yeah when we can do that I
don't know when but uh
all right
I mean I could do a Saturday if you guys
could do it I'm down next Saturday the
7th I will see I'll let y'all know
during the week okay okay all right so
maybe maybe not next Saturday yeah we'll
we'll see uh and then you know I will be
streaming more on my YouTube channel as
well uh so definitely go and follow me
on YouTube follow me on Twitter too I
appreciate everyone coming through here
and uh we'll see you next week no doubt
Lord sorry we're gonna find people to
find you what you got going on Sir
you're not going to work because of
course you know that's how I do on
Sundays I'm going to work but I did I'm
in the chat I just put the link to the
crystal Dynamics survey about uh what
you would like to see in Legacy of Kane
game if you love Legacy of Kane if you
don't even know what it is look it up
dude we knew this series to come back
I'm a big Legacy of Game Fan baby this
all the way
the links in the chat let's go let's
bring this game back thank you that's my
PSA for the week
no I'm done what I'm done look on
Twitter look on Twitter
account I love it uh they tagged us all
so everyone could see it it is
ridiculous it's like a meme of saying
Jim bones and Mr Harrison and they're
passing a paper together and the paper
says when he reads it it says let's
snitched together yo wait hold on what
oh yo Jimmy bones Mr Harrison Stitch the
yo
wow that is crazy the lead up to the
Brussels trip
wow
wow you got to see this they just I'm
gonna check it out freaky legs creepy
legs put it up I can't even reach it
that's so crazy anyway can't look at
five people five percent's not going to
sleep or the valari pillows well first
first and foremost I want to give a
heartfelt uh uh
cry to everybody that has been affected
by uh
uh you know I have a lot of friends
South Carolina you know stuff like that
uh you know Mojo had uh
um a military come and evacuate him out
of there wow uh shout out to to Monkey
um graphic God everybody keeps asking
about uh attic and I show listen graphic
God is working on the overlays and
stitching together we already have the
intro and stuff
um
whenever everything is right with his
situation then we'll be able to do that
so we have friends and and partners in
the community that we care about and we
we actually you know are waiting on so
please everybody you know check on
graphic God check on all your friends uh
that's in that region that is suffering
from this because it's real bad it looks
really terrible
um you can catch me on Twitter acting
the fool and you can catch me on
fortnite uh trying to get some stuff in
uh so that's about it for me I'm
starving I'm sleepy and I have to use
the bathroom just for confirmation it
was confirmed shout out that nible
Horizon zero Dawn remake is in the works
and they have yeah they're gonna pay for
it yeah it is what it is but um yeah
we're gonna talk about that on the attic
yeah but again suit everybody up in the
realm today a lot of fun and all that we
got some more fun stuff plans there's
cool things for the rest of the year but
that's all I got and on that note we are
good son we good to go oh we got one
more hold on so we did we get another
Super Chat you better read these mad
fast because I don't want to be hostage
we got a tenant obb two dollar Super
Chat Australia's awake what the hell is
going on
our Rd two dollars which at Horizon
remake rumored as per VTC yes it has
been confirmed that's crazy man
yeah we're good all right cool everybody
enjoy your Sunday we out of here peace
peace
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign